Die Freak Show wird freundlich unterstützt durch Hörerpost.
Wir haben Hörerpost bekommen.
6,4 Millionen Scoville Heat Units.
Meine Fresse!
Das ist noch nicht scharfe Schokolade.
Die war scharf.
Hattest du sie denn jetzt eigentlich aufgeteilt gehabt und auch vertilgt und alles?
Die ist noch nicht komplett vertilgt.
Hurra!
Und dann kriegen sie für ihre Kartellabsprache, dürften sie wahrscheinlich nochmal zweistellige Milliardenbeträge an Strafen rein kriegen von den Regressforderungen ihrer Kunden, mal ganz abgesehen von den politischen Konsequenzen und was weiß ich, wie viele Manager sie jetzt ins Kittchen schicken dürfen, mal ganz abgesehen. Und so ganz nebenbei kommt dann irgendwie China und sagst so, ach ja, übrigens, und ab nächstes Jahr macht ihr dann mal irgendwie 10 Prozent mal hier Elektroautos in eurer Flotte, das ist doch sicherlich kein Problem für euch, oder? Und die so, was, wie? Schicken jetzt einen Brandbrief dahin, irgendwie an die chinesische Regierung, weinerlich.
Das konnte ja keiner ahnen.
Und überhaupt, Leute, hört einfach Freak Show. Also das ist sowas von dumm und durch die Politik gedeckt. Ich meine, solche hirntoten Vögel wie dieser Dobrindt, der jetzt irgendwie auch diese ganzen Diesel-Skandalen durch einfach überhaupt null Feuer gemacht hat. Ich meine, man hätte ja jetzt mal zumindest mal zwei Jahre irgendwie schon mal früher dabei sein können.
Aber nicht mal in der… Ja, aber der Dobrindt ist doch Scherge von den Autokonzernen.
Ja, nicht nur das, auch dieser, wie hieß der, Vorgänger, der jetzt bei der ETSA, bei dem Automobilinteressenverbund ist, dieser andere CDU-Haini, hab ich den Namen jetzt vergessen.
Aber immerhin, es wird gemunkelt. BMW will in den i3 größere Batterien reinbauen.
Es wird gemunkelt. Es wird nur gemunkelt. Die sollen einfach mal…
Nein, aber das ist die einzige Firma, die ein ordentliches Elektroauto auf dem Markt hat, die einzige deutsche.
Opel?
Ordentlich.
Wieso hieß es da nicht der Herr Amthel?
Ja, den gibt's halt auch nicht.
Das wäre der Ampera. Der Ampera ist der Chevy Bolt. Und Chevy, also GM, hat die Marke Opel gerade an Peugeot verkauft. Du glaubst doch nicht im Ernst, dass der Ampera, also dass der Chevy Bolt als Opel Ampera auf den deutschen Markt kommt? Das wird nicht passieren. Die haben das Teil gerade verkauft, vielleicht als Chevy Bolt. Aber es ist ja so, dass die mit der Produktion ja schon nicht hinterherkommen. Die Chevy-Dealer in Amerika, die so ein Teil irgendwann mal auf dem Hof haben, die reiben sich nur die Augen, wie schnell das Ding vom Hof wieder runter ist, weil die Leute es ihnen aus den Händen reißen. Und es ist völlig unklar, ob GM die nicht bauen will oder nicht in der Lage ist. Aber auf jeden Fall gibt es nicht genug davon.
Weil es auch nur mit Augen zwingen kann.
Ja, das ist ein Phantom.
Ich kann das immer gar nicht so glauben, dass diese riesengroßen Firmen, die ja bestimmt auch eine Menge Leute bezahlen, wie die Zukunft dann so ist und wie der Markt sich entwickeln wird, dass die das nicht im Blick haben, dass demnächst die dicke Elektrowelle kommt und dass die da keine Pläne haben. Das kann ich ja immer noch nicht glauben.
Ich verstehe. Also nicht mal ein Modell, also nicht mal eins. Und wenn es nur eine S-Klasse ist, so als Showcase oder so, so ein Extended S-Klasse, hier voll E, irgendwie voll geil. Nicht mal das.
Das ist wie mit der Telekom und dem Kupfer. Na wieso? Das liegt doch hier alles rum. Da pressen wir jetzt einfach mal raus, was wir rauspressen können.
Das Kupfer, das wird auch nicht verboten und darf demnächst nicht mehr durch die Innenstadt fahren. Das ist ein bisschen was anderes.
Das liefert halt auch nicht die Bandbreiten, die man braucht. Das ist schon ein vergleichbares Problem. Also es gibt einfach zu wenig und das ist das, warum ich sage, das ist auch ein deutsches Problem. Es gibt hier einfach zu wenig Diskruptionsbereitschaft. Also dieses Festhalten, wie es immer war und das wird auch weiter so funktionieren, das ist tief kulturell drin in diesem Land. Und mit ein paar Sachen ist man ja wirklich ganz gut gefahren, weil das irgendwie so langsam sich nur gewandelt hat, dass die Anpassung da ist und generell so Maschinen bauen und so weiter. Das läuft ja eigentlich immer noch total super in Deutschland und da ist man irgendwie auch so halbwegs...
Die Endgrunden sind ja auch nicht abgezockt, deswegen müssen sie das ordentlich machen. Da gibt es auch Konkurrenz aus international, aber halt Kupferkabel.
Ja, da haben wir halt das Problem, dass wir gar nicht die Marktvoraussetzungen haben, damit sich sowas wie Disruption überhaupt einstellen kann. Also es wird zumindest verhindert und es wird halt von der Politik verhindert. Und gewisser Hinsicht wird es eben auch im Automarkt verhindert. Nur jetzt kommen halt Kräfte, die halt die deutsche Politik nicht im Griff hat und auch die deutsche Automobilindustrie nicht im Griff hat, weil sie sich eben die ganze Zeit so ein Innovationsverbot gegeben haben, beziehungsweise sich in irgendeiner Innovationsblase befunden haben, in der sie meinten, sie würden innovativ sein, weil sie jetzt irgendwie ihrem 128. Button in der BMW-Konsole noch einen 129.
Denken alle, sie sind Nokia und ihnen kann niemand was.
So war das ja bisher immer, wenn ich mal wieder bei VW bin wegen einer Scheißreparatur, weil wieder irgendein Verbrennungsteil kaputtgegangen ist und ich dann immer so die Wartezeit damit verbringe, mich von irgendeinem Händler, so einem Quatschhain, die da vollplappern zu lassen und so tue, als würde ich mir jetzt gleich vielleicht ein Auto kaufen und dann halt irgendwann sagen so, ja haben sie irgendwie keine ordentlichen Antriebe und so und dann immer dieselbe Leier kommt, so ja, nee, ach und das mit dem Elektro, das setze ich ja nie durch oder das dauert ja noch lang oder so. Also die haben sich so ihr Lied so ein bisschen geändert, aber es ist halt einfach, merkst du einfach, dass die einfach zu keiner aufrichtigen Diskussion in der Lage sind, aber jedes halbe Jahr, wo ich da bin und dieses Gespräch führe, merke ich, wie sie einfach immer fünf Zentimeter kleiner geworden sind und nicht mehr so laut reden, weil sie langsam einfach Schiss haben. Also sie haben wirklich richtig Schiss da und zu Recht. Also ich meine, VW, wenn sie das so weitermachen, dann entfernen die sich noch irgendwie von diesem Planeten. Die können dann noch 30 Jahre Reparaturen für ihren alten Scheiß machen und das war's.
Aber haben die nicht letztes Jahr wieder ihre Zahlen rausgelegt und denen geht's blendend eigentlich und haben wieder verdient wie nie zuvor?
Ja, aber das sind doch alles nur Momentaufnahmen. Man muss einfach sehen, wie das langfristig ist und das kann sich sehr schnell ändern. Ja, ich meine, Nokia ging es auch blendend, als das iPhone kam.
Blackberry ging es auch total geil, irgendwie voll.
Zwei Jahre lang ging es noch richtig nach oben mit ihnen. Und dann ging es einfach mal so schnell ratzefatze bergab. Und das ist das, was mich halt so ärgert, dass man da eigentlich den Leuten, die da arbeiten, eigentlich sehr unfair gegenüber ist, weil die müssen es ausbaden. Das Management, das kommt schon wieder irgendwo unter.
Die werden dafür gezwungen, irgendwelche komischen Aggregate zu bauen, die so tun, als wären sie ganz umweltfreundlich, wenn sie getestet werden. Weil das war sicherlich nicht der Lohnwurf in der Entwicklung, sondern das kam von ganz oben.
Das kam von ganz oben und es kommt halt von sehr weit oben. Und vielleicht werden wir auch noch sehen, wer noch mit am Tisch steht.
Aber ich habe mich bei dieser Mini-Messe da auch so mit zum Autohändler unterhalten und meinte so, na ja, wenn die Batterien erst mal günstig genug sind, dann lohnt es sich einfach nicht mehr, einen Verbrenner zu bauen. Und dann, na ja, meinte er so, ja, ob das so kommt, meinte ich ja, wenn der Preis weiter so steigt, wird das kommen. Die Frage ist nur, ob in fünf oder fünfzehn Jahren. Und dann guckte er mich etwas betröppelt an und meinte nur so, na wollen hoffen, dass es nicht so schnell kommt. Er würde davon leben, dass Benziner so viel kaputtgehen.
Ja, da bricht echt eine ganze Menge zusammen. Und es ist ja nicht nur diese Antriebsgeschichte, was ich glaube, wo ich Ihnen in gewisser Hinsicht noch was zugestehen würde, dass Sie das jetzt nicht komplett aus dem Blick haben, aber Software wird eine viel größere Rolle spielen in Autos als derzeit noch. Und ich rede jetzt nicht nur von der Software im Sinne von, ich steuere meinen Motor, damit er die richtigen Zahlen ausgibt und die richtigen Zündungen macht, sondern einfach Software im Sinne von integriert in mein Leben. Und ich glaube, das ist auch so einer der Gründe, warum Apple das Thema Auto für sich so entdeckt hat, weil sie da halt nicht ausgeklinkt werden sollen. Weil einfach für viele Leute, dass das Auto einfach nach dem Wohnzimmer so der wichtigste Medien-Abspiel- und Kommunikationsort ist.
Ja, also ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass das halt nur eine Firma wirklich begreift, dass man eine Lösung verkaufen muss und nicht ein Stück Hardware. Und das halt Tesla, weil die halt mit ihrem Elektro-Herangehensweise eine Lösung verkaufen mit Supercharger-Netzwerk und so weiter und mit Software, die man updaten kann. So ein VW verkauft dir ein Stück Hardware. Und in diesem Stück Hardware ist nochmal ein Stück Hardware drin. Das kannst du anfassen und das macht Licht. Und für die ist halt das ein Stück Hardware, was man in ein Stück Hardware reinbaut, aber nicht ein Gesamtsystem, eine Gesamtlösung.
Ja, und für einmal USB reinstecken musst du da irgendwie einen halben Tag irgendwie deine Karre dahin bringen, Transport Dinge. Genau, nachts. Und dann musst du noch 60 Euro dafür bezahlen, dass ein Techniker ein Software-Update gemacht hat. Irre!
Wirklich! Software ist für die halt auch nur ein Mittel, um ein Stück Hardware zu verkaufen. Und wenn du die Software änderst, dann hast du quasi eine neue Hardware gekauft und deswegen musst du für die Software bezahlen. Das ist halt... Es erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Apple und die PC Kistenschieber. Also die Kistenschieber haben halt nur ein Stück Hardware verkauft. Ob da nur Windows drauf läuft oder nicht, war denen dann auch meistens egal.
Ja, hier wird noch gefordert, dass man irgendwie doch mal Individualverkehr an sich hinterfragen soll. Das kann man natürlich tun, aber ich sag nur...
Nicht hier.
Na, ich sag nur...
Ich weiß nicht, als jemand, der 25 Jahre sich im wesentlichen im öffentlichen Nahverkehr bewegt hat, ob ich da an der Stelle noch irgendwas diskutieren will, also eigentlich nicht...
Es war alles schön, oder was im öffentlichen Nahverkehr?
Du hast deinen Teil getan.
Keine Ahnung, ich war nicht dabei.
Du hast immer Freude gehabt.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, nee, eigentlich nicht so. Du wurdest es jedem empfehlen. Na, sagen wir mal so, in Berlin funktioniert das relativ gut. Es gibt natürlich immer Raum für Verbesserungen. Aber immer, wenn ich in so Städten bin, wo es so gar nicht funktioniert, dann freue ich mich, dass man in Berlin auch einfach irgendwie an die Haltestelle gehen kann, meistens, und dann kommt eine U-Bahn und ich muss nicht vorher mir überlegen, ob ich jetzt sofort aus dem Haus gehen muss oder noch eine Viertelstunde warten kann, weil die Züge nur alle 20 Minuten fahren. Also das ist halt so ein Ding. Ich erlebe das halt in München dann ab und zu und so. Das ist irgendwie, insofern, klar kann man Individualverkehr hinterfragen, aber der wird nicht weggehen.
Das glaube ich auch, dass er nicht weggehen wird und deswegen muss man halt auch schon mit dem Status quo arbeiten. Das ist so ein bisschen wie, jetzt müssen alle vegan essen. Ja, das kann man fordern und so, aber...
Vegetarisch reicht schon mal.
So ungesunder Mangelernährung.
Genau, wie öffentlicher Nahverkehr.
Öffentlicher Nahverkehr stärkt aber das Immunsystem. Also es gibt glaube ich nichts, was das Immunsystem so stärkt wie öffentlicher Nahverkehr.
Kleine Kinder in der Kita, das ist bestimmt auch nicht schlecht.
Ja, das ist auch öffentlicher Nahverkehr.
Hier zum Thema noch Akkupalütze und so weiter. Nee, später hoffentlich. Hatt ich noch so einen Link ins Workflow getan zu dieser, hat ein Kollege rausgefunden, zu dieser Eco-Capsule, die ich ja schon auch sehr putzig fand, wo es irgendwie, es kommen jetzt immer mehr so kleine Ideen auch hervor, so autark und self-sufficient und wie man das alles mit dem Leben gestalten kann. Und da haben glaube ich Leute, SK war glaube ich Slowakei, steht das hier, genau, Slovak Republic, so eine kleine süße Eco-Capsule gemacht, die so ein Ei mit Windturbine, mit Solarzelle, mit Regen-Auffang-System und Regen-Wasser-Filter und alles halt so self-contained. Und ist nicht so ganz preiswert, muss man gleich mal dazu sagen. Aber prinzipiell finde ich das ja auch ein ganz schnuffiges Konzept. Also gerade, wenn man sich mal so irgendwie so ein Stück Wald irgendwo, vielleicht in einer Zwangs-Ersteigerung geschnappt hat und da nichts draufbauen darf, kann man sich zumindest so eine kleine Eco-Capsule als kleine Andockstation hinstellen. Und im Prinzip wäre sowas halt auch für so ein Segelboot eigentlich voll gut, wenn du da so ein Segelboot baust, Windturbine, Solarpanels, Wasser. Also natürlich kannst du dir eine Windturbine und ein Solarpanel aufs Boot schrauben, aber es gibt jetzt kein Boot, was du so kaufen kannst, was einfach sagt, hier self-sufficient. Also auch Wasseraufbereitung und alles kriegen wir hin. Und mit E-Motor vor allen Dingen, das wäre zum Beispiel beim Segelboot jetzt auch noch vergleichsweise innovativ.
Was ich nicht so ganz verstehe bei dieser Eco-Capsule, wo ist jetzt der entscheidende Unterschied zu einem Wohnwagen? Man kann es nicht bewegen.
Na ja, du kannst es ja immer auf dem Hänger raufstellen. Also dann hast du deinen Wohnwagen.
Ja gut, aber du kannst ja auch gleich einen Wohnwagen nehmen. Also ich meine für den Preis von 30.000 kannst du ja irgendwie so einen...
30.000, stand da 30.000? Da stand 80 oder?
Da stand 80.000.
80.000! Das kann man hier auch mit dem Wohnwagen ziehen.
Erster 50 Stück Preis ist das, also ich meine, das ist jetzt nur so ein Konzept.
Ey, lasst uns ein paar Märk machen, wir gucken uns da zwei Jahre noch mal die Sache, in zwei Jahren gibt es das Leben nicht mehr.
Ich sag ja auch nicht, dass das jetzt alle sich kaufen sollen, sondern einfach nur so ein Beispiel für...
Aber du kriegst halt für 30.000, kriegst du halt einen Wohnwagen, der viel, viel, viel größer ist als das Teil mit Solar-Panels und Pipapo und irgendwie...
Und das Windrad kannst du da auch nach oben hochschrauben.
Das scheiß Windrad, was ich bezweifle, dass das überhaupt irgend...
Ne, ne, ne, ne, diese Windturbinen machen mehr als jede Solarzelle.
Die sind aber viel zu niedrig.
Aber die kosten auch nichts, dafür zahlt doch keine 80.000.
Lest euch da erstmal durch, jetzt bevor ihr irgendwie drauf abreitet, wenn euch das interessiert, was das macht, was die da überhaupt alles einbauen und was da drin ist. Also, das ist ja wie gesagt nicht nur einfach, wir haben da irgendwo mal ein paar Solarzellen draufgeschraubt und Windturbine. Es geht ja tatsächlich darum, dass es komplett sozusagen self-sufficient ist, auch mit der Wasseraufbereitung und so weiter.
Okay, jetzt sammelt sich auch noch gleich das Regenwasser ein.
Und wird gefiltert und so.
Man muss auch seine eigene Pisse trinken, ja?
Ja, aber wer ist denn da?
Regenwasser!
Du pisst doch nicht auf deine Wohnung drauf.
Wer ist denn da die Zielgruppe? Reiche Leute, die zu viel Geld haben. Siehst du da den Preis?
1200 Kilogramm.
Also hier die Windturbine macht 750 Watt Output. Auf Booten haben sich auch mittlerweile diese Windturbinen total durchgesetzt. Auf dem Segelboot macht es natürlich eh Sinn, weil du viel Wind um dich rum hast. Aber die machen einfach deutlich mehr als Solarpanels.
Ja, ist ja auch auf dem Meer immer besser Wind.
Und es gibt vor allen Dingen mittlerweile auch extrem leise. Früher die ersten, die da so, siehst du auch bei älteren Segelbooten gelegentlich noch, die machen dann so nervige Surgeräusche, aber die ganz modernen Vertreter sind super, super leise. Auch bei viel Wind. Und das ist auf jeden Fall auch eine coole Sache. Die kann man sich schon mal auf dem Wohnwagen auch schrauben, mit so einem Teleskop, wie bei den Sendewagen, die dann ihre Antenne so teleskopmäßig hochfahren.
Aber die Batterien mit 10 Kilowattstunden ist fast ein bisschen überdimensioniert, hab ich das Gefühl.
10 Kilowattstunden?
Du willst ja da auch dein Digital-Live-No-Watt-Lifestyle noch weiterführen.
So warte mal, 10 Kilo? Achso, naja, du musst ja die ganzen Solar-Kramen, denen du da einsammelst, auch irgendwie irgendwo hin schweigern.
Die Solarzelle hast du doch gesehen, die macht bestenfalls 1,5 bis 2 Kilowatt Peak. 0,6 Kilowatt Peak. Das heißt, ok, du kannst dann 14 Tage Strom oder drei Wochen Strom in der Batterie speichern, aber das ist irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, stellst du das dann in die Höhle?
Ja gut, aber wenn du da irgendwie mal einen Staubsauger in ordentlichem betreiben willst, oder einen Tosa.
Oder einen Laubbläser.
So eine Dinge kannst du ja komplett vergessen, würde ich mal sagen.
Oder wenn du dein Auto laden willst. Was?
Wenn du 10 Kilowattstunden hast?
Das Ding hat ja vielleicht auch noch eine Heizung.
10 Kilowattstunden, da kannst du irgendwie...
Nein, eine Heizung würde ich so einsehen.
Also wenn das Wasser heizt, zum Beispiel und so weiter...
Also meine Jahresablenkung, da steht was von 140 Kilowatt im Jahr.
Ist da eine Heizung drin?
Also ich kann es jetzt nicht... Heating, Floorheating, oh. Also...
Das wird ein reiches Hipster-Mobil, ich sag's euch.
Es geht halt darum, dass du wirklich keine Schnur dran steckst und trotzdem all den Komfort in diesem kleinen Raum hast.
Aber es kommt sozusagen komplett ohne Gas aus.
Ja, und das ist einfach nur ein Beispiel für... Und da werden wir noch ganz viele solche Konzepte in nächster Zeit sehen, wo sich jetzt die Leute halt natürlich so ein bisschen vermehrt Gedanken machen, wie man so autarke Systeme bauen kann. Das wird sicherlich...
Was kostet so eine Windanlage, so eine kleine, wenn man dir so das Boot kauft?
Müsste ich mal gerade gucken. Aber... Also super billig sind sie nicht. Ich würde mal schätzen... Einstellig 1000... Könnte es sein. Aber... Ob jetzt... Nah an der 10 oder eher so im mittelpreisigen Bereich. Ich weiß... Ich kann mal Elisa fragen, die weiß das bestimmt. Die hat ja schon ganz viel recherchiert für die Matenka. Ja, aber wie gesagt, die sind schon ziemlich cool. Die machen richtig Druck auf der Leitung. Tja, aber bloß ich weiß halt nicht, ob das dann eben an Land auch gut funktioniert oder ob man dann wirklich so einen Teleskop-Arm braucht, den man dann so ausfährt, damit das irgendwie über die Waldwipfel hinüber rast.
Also in dem Bild sieht es so aus, als würde da auf einer Lichtung in einem Wald stehen und da hast du garantiert nicht allzu viel Wind. Wenn du das Teil jetzt oben auf dem Hügel stellst, dann könnte es ganz gut gehen.
Naja, ich fand es ja auch nur ein schönes kleines Beispiel.
Ich finde es aber super. Ich finde es nur, sagen wir mal, die Käuferschicht, die jetzt hier eigentlich begeistert in die Luft springen muss. Das sind Leute, die haben so viel Geld. Die wollen auch mit zwei Leuten irgendwie.
Da steht ja auch ne First Fifty irgendwie. Sie fangen ja da erstmal an irgendwie. Und dann sagen sie, wir wollen jetzt den Preis irgendwie dann schon auch noch besser hinkriegen danach. Und so weiter.
Und falls du eine Bike Order machst, falls du irgendwie so...
So einen Center Park dir zusammenbauen willst.
Ja, für irgendeine Hipster Party auf einer Insel. Jeder hat sein eigenes Ei. Da gab es noch neulich diese geile Katastrophe in den USA, wo wir das auf so einer Karibik-Insel, wo sie so für die Reichen so eine Party machen wollten, die so komplett desorganisiert war, wo es dann irgendwie am Ende nichts zu trinken gab und nichts, und dann die so die ganzen Reichnipser, da alle evakuiert werden mussten, um dann irgendwie so vor dem sicheren Tod bewahrt zu werden. Da wäre das wahrscheinlich genau das Richtige gewesen. Dann kriegt jeder so seine eigene kleine Luxuszelle.
Also hier so ein Windrouter, der hier bis, was steht hier, so eine Tabelle, der sagen wir mal bei Windgeschwindigkeit von 12 Metern die Sekunde macht er so ca. 200 bis 250 Watt oder halt bis 450 bei richtig entsprechend Wind, kostet 1.500. Das ist nicht so teuer.
Genau, aber der, der da jetzt war, war angeblich 750 Watt lieferend, peak. Genau, und das sind...
Aber es ist immer die Frage, bei was für einem Wind, ne? Also wie viel Wind...
Kurz bevor das Teil umfällt.
Gut, aber wie oft hast du jetzt Sturm, ne? Du hast halt in der Regel so laues Lüftchen. Gerade wenn du im Sommer unterwegs bist, ist da nicht so viel zu holen. Also du musst schon am Wasser sein. Da könnte das vielleicht funktionieren, aber dann hauen die vielleicht an die Nachbarn weg, weil es zu laut ist.
Wie gesagt, laut sind die gar nicht mehr. Also in so einer Marina, da ist ja Boot an Boot, sozusagen. Und ich weiß noch so, die ersten Mal als ich da mitgefahren bin, da gab es immer so Raunen, wenn man so einen Parkplatz quasi neben so einem Boot mit so einem alten Windgenerator hat, weil halt die ganze Zeit dann so ssss. Dann hat man halt nebenan gefragt, ob sie den dann vielleicht festbinden oder ausmachen, wenn sie fertig sind mit Stromverbrauchen. Beziehungsweise am Marien hat man ja eh eigentlich Landstrom und die haben es dann einfach nur nicht festgebunden und mittlerweile hört man die gar nicht mehr.
Aber hast du denn in so einem Hafen, hast du doch sowieso immer dieses Klink Klink Klink von den Seilen, die an den Masten...
Von so einem da Rotor direkt neben dir.
Das ist was anderes.
Ja, ist was anderes. Nervt mehr. Genau. Naja, wollte ich ja nur mal kurz erwähnen haben. Und du hattest doch jetzt auch noch was schönes, oder? Solarstrom-Flatrate.
Ah ja, genau. Und zwar, das ist das erste Mal, dass ich tatsächlich gehört hab, dass es sowas gibt. Da gibt's einen Hersteller, der heißt Sonnen. Beziehungsweise, ich weiß nicht, ob die auch die Batterie herstellen. Die bieten an, dass, wenn man sich einen Sonnen-Collektor und eine Speicherbatterie auf das Dach stellt, also natürlich das Solarzeug, also die Kollektoren aufs Dach, die Photovoltaik aufs Dach, die Batterie irgendwo hin, und dann so ein Kistchen montiert, das so ein bisschen steuert, dann haben die die Möglichkeit, deinen Akku zu laden, also deine Batterie. Und die machen irgendwie relativ viel Geld damit, dass wenn irgendwo Überkapazität im Netz ist, dass sie in der Lage sind, all die Verbraucher, die sie haben, die kaufen dann den überflüssigen Strom ein, oder die kriegen ja teilweise Geld dafür, dass sie den abnehmen, richtig? Genau, die können irgendwie minutengenau extrem viel Last ins Netz schalten. Das verhindert, dass du ein Überangebot an Strom im Netz hast. Und damit machen die relativ viel Geld, weil es kaum andere gibt, die halt auf Bedarf mal eben so Megawatt Last ins Netz schalten können. Und das vergüten dir dadurch, dass du eine gewisse Flatrate hast, die du im Jahr verbrauchen kannst. Und dafür bezahlst du dann nichts. Und nur oberhalb dieser Flatrate, die genauen Zahlen müsst ihr euch da mal angucken, aber es ist eigentlich so, dass du im Prinzip den Jahresbedarf, den du hast, über diese Flatrate ganz locker gedeckt bekommst. Was den netten Nebeneffekt zum Beispiel hat, wenn du jetzt mit einer Wärmepumpe heizt, dann hast du das Problem, dass du natürlich in der Übergangszeit und vor allen Dingen im Winter sehr viel Strom verbrauchst. Aber im Sommer fast keinen Strom verbrauchst. Wenn du aber diese Flatrate auf ein Jahr hast, dann kannst du darüber, dass du im Sommer relativ wenig Strom verbrauchst und im Winter viel, kannst du es mitteln. Dann kommst du im Prinzip bei Null raus und musst für deinen Strom nichts bezahlen. Du hast natürlich irgendwie die Investitionskosten für die Solarzellen und die Batterie. Das ist wahrscheinlich eine sehr, sehr große Batterie, oder?
Na die sagen, das lohnt sich dann nach zehn Jahren?
Na die sagen, dass du ungefähr das, was du an. Peakleistung Solar auf dem Dach hast, an Batterie hast. Ich hab mich halt da mit diesem Vertreter unterhalten, der hat das relativ genau erklärt. Es ist halt auch so, dass die gar nicht so viel laden, aber dass die eben die Möglichkeit haben, extrem kurzfristig sehr viel Last ins Netz zu tun. Und dafür kriegen die halt das Geld. Und deswegen kriegst du den Strom, den sie ansonsten so haben, kriegst du halt quasi umme. Also hier siehst du es zum Beispiel, wenn du hier 5,5 Kilowatt Peak auf dem Dach hast und eine 6 Kilowattstunden Akku, dann bekommst du 4250 Kilowattstunden Strom im Jahr für umsonst.
Und zählt mein Tesla auch als Akku?
Im Prinzip ja, aber also sie können das wohl noch nicht steuern.
Ja, aber das wird ja in der Zukunft kommen, oder? Ja, wenn die ganzen Autos, wenn dann in 50 Jahren jeder Elektroauto hat, dann nachts irgendwie Stromüberfluss, wahrscheinlich nachts nicht, aber tagsüber und dann wird das in die Autos reingeschoben.
Ja, also.
Oder auch wieder rausgezogen teilweise.
Na ja, also er meinte, rausziehen gar nicht. Also das ganze System baut im Wesentlichen darauf, dass du den Strom aus dem Akku auch selber verbrauchst.
Ja, ist schon klar. Aber stell dir vor, in 50 Jahren werden alle Autos, die es so gibt, alles Elektroautos sind und dann wahrscheinlich schon auch im Bereich von 100 Kilowatt. Das haben zwar jetzt nur die großen Elektroautos, aber in der Zukunft wird das ja besser werden. Wenn du da Millionen von Autos hast, die alle eine 100 Kilowatt-Batterie drin haben, dann hast du doch deinen Riesenspeicher, mit dem du super prima arbeiten kannst.
Also er meinte halt, dass es wirklich dieses Minutengenau ist, was es bringt, weil du kannst halt selbst so ein Gas-Speaker-Kraftwerk nicht im Minutentakt an- und ausmachen. Relativ schnell, aber wenn du halt in der Lage bist, wirklich im Minutentakt halt das Zeug, also entweder Strom zu liefern oder Strom zu ziehen, dass du damit halt das Netz dann stabilisieren kannst.
Aber wenn die gar keinen Strom ziehen, das heißt, die füllen ja dann deine Batterie nur, aber da müssen ja auch dafür sorgen, dass meine Batterie möglichst auch immer leer ist, oder wie?
Ne, er meinte, es ist nicht allzu viel. Also das sind dann halt mal 300 Watt oder mal 600 Watt oder so. Jaja, genau, das sind aber so kurze Bursts, die halt das Netz dann stabilisieren und dadurch eben, ja, das Rechenbeispiel, klar. Also was du halt hast, sind die Investitionskosten, weil du musst dir die Solarzelle und die Batterie musst du dir halt anschaffen. Aber ansonsten steckst du da im Prinzip nur dein Kistchen da in die Steckdose. Der macht dann irgendwie bei dir WLAN oder so, ich weiß es nicht, oder ob der auch LTE macht. Und dann, ja, also insofern, man muss denen natürlich halt auch glauben, dass es die noch die nächsten zehn Jahre gibt, damit sich das über die Zeit amortisiert. Aber fand ich mal sehr, sehr spannend, vor allen Dingen, dass dieses Last-ins-Netz-Schalten wirklich so viel bringt, dass die mal eben den Strom verschenken können, mehr oder weniger.
Aber die sollten schon mit den Elektroauto-Herstellern, Tesla, wie auch immer, zusammenarbeiten, weil so ein Elektroauto ist doch die Superbatterie.
Ja, im Prinzip, er meinte, also im Prinzip könnte man das auch mit einem Elektroauto machen, auch heute schon. Dann müsstest du allerdings das halt das Auto so konfigurieren, dass du es halt bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt lädst und dann mehr oder weniger nur noch die Ladesäule schaltest. Das Auto, das merkt, dass diese Ladesäule hochkommt, dann lädt es. Und wenn die Ladesäule wieder ausgeht, dann lädt das Auto halt nicht mehr.
Genau, du sagst, ein Auto nur macht man nur 90 Prozent voll, weil den Rest kriege ich for free.
Also es ist wohl so, bei den derzeitigen Teslas kannst du tatsächlich keinen Strom wieder rausziehen.
Ja, das werden die auch noch irgendwann ändern.
Aber es müsste eigentlich zumindest bei Tesla softwermäßig relativ einfach sein, dem Auto zu sagen, so jetzt lädst du, jetzt hörst du wieder auf und jetzt lädst du wieder. Also, keine Ahnung, aber der Typ, der das da erzählt hat, der war vorher bei Tesla gewesen, jetzt ist er bei denen. Er wüsste, wie das ist mit den Teslas und das geht gerade momentan noch nicht. Also Strom wieder rausziehen geht nicht, geht wohl auch bei anderen Elektroautos nicht.
Und ich vermute, dass Tesla unter Umständen auch in diesem Segment der intelligenten Bestromung von allem ohnehin mitmischen möchte. Die haben noch diese Solar City, Powerwalls und so. Also die sind ja dick im Boot mit ihrer Factory da. Das ist deren Konzept. Intelligent, Energie durch die Gegend schieben dahin, wo man es braucht.
Wir haben dann sehr verstanden, dass sie nicht nur Autos verkaufen können, sondern das drum herum muss halt auch alles passen. Und das ist auch nicht nur aus, weil er ein Öko ist, sondern weil es halt auch die Kohle der Zukunft ist.
Ja, und das ist alles so intelligent angelegt, da kommt halt die deutsche Automobilindustrie irgendwie nicht hinterher, weil die denkt halt die ganze Zeit immer nur über Autos nach und nicht über universelle Lösungen.
Tja, übrigens so eine Windturbine kostet doch so ein bis zwei Tausend Euro nur.
Ja, hab ich doch gesagt, war nicht so teuer. Ich hab da geguckt, die waren alle so in dem Bereich.
Wie viel?
Ja, 300, 400 Watt.
Also die, die sie da in der EcoCapsule verbauen, hab ich jetzt nicht so spontan gefunden. Muss man noch mal ein bisschen recherchieren wahrscheinlich. Aber die so Top-of-the-Line-Boots-Generatoren, die auch leise sind, kosten so.
Warum steht das nicht auf jedem Haus?
Ja, gute Frage.
Also hier zum Beispiel bei diesem Ottobock-Haus am Hauptbahnhof, da haben sie ja diese futuristisch aussehenden Windgabeln da oben raufgeschraubt und ja.
Und auch so Rotoren und so senkrecht stehende Rotoren.
Ja, das sind die, die nicht so einen Druck machen. Das sind die moderneren. Also die, die man so sieht auf dem Land mit diesen drei Rotorrädern, da in der dicker Wind kommt, da müssen sie ja auch abschalten, weil das sonst zu schnell wird und so weiter. Und der Druck auf den Masten ist ja auch sehr stark. Und da gibt es welche, die drehen sich nur, wie soll man sagen?
Aus dem Wind halt raus.
Na, die Rotierenden können sich ja nicht aus dem Wind rausdrehen.
Da ist die Achse halt in Richtung Boden und nicht in Richtung Wind. So könnte man das sagen. Und dadurch ist das, die können sich so schnell drehen, wie sie wollen. Da ist sozusagen kein Druck auf dem Masten.
Ja, du hast aber ein anderes Problem mit den Dingern. Die brauchen eine gewisse Mindestwindgeschwindigkeit. Und dann musst du sie starten. Das heißt, du musst den Motor anwerfen, damit das Ding auf eine Mindestdrehgeschwindigkeit kommt. Damit du hinterher dann wieder Strom aus dem Wind machen kannst.
Na gut, kostet halt auch wieder. Habe ich aber nichts von gehört, dass das so ist.
Also die Stehenden auf dem Mast mit dem Propeller, die sind halt deutlich effektiver. Die Pi mal Daumen-Rechnung ist die Fläche, die so der Flügel überstreicht, ist so das, was du an Energie harvesting kannst. Und du hast halt einfach bei dem Ding, erstens ist es oben, weiter oben, und dann hast du halt eine größere Fläche, die du überstreichst mit dem Rotor. Dadurch, dass der so direkt im Wind hängt.
Außerdem würden sie die ja sonst nicht bauen hätten, schon umgestellt, weil die wollen ja auch möglichst effektive Windräder bauen. Wie auch immer.
Und ich bilde mir ja eigentlich ein, dass du, zumindest ja vielleicht nicht bei allen Modellen, aber dass du die quasi quer zum Wind drehen kannst, und dann nimmst du die Angriffsfläche raus. Aber diese Windturbinen fürs Boot, die sind halt bis Hurricane-Stärke, ISO, was auch immer, sonst wie zertifiziert, und die Spitzen von den Blättern erreichen dann auch fast Schallgeschwindigkeit, aber fallen dann nicht auseinander, immerhin.
Na ja, die kennt das Boot trotzdem, ne?
Ja klar, aber ich meine, ob die Frage, warum hat das nicht jeder auf dem Dach und so weiter, also das könnte man theoretisch tun.
Gut.
Ist vielleicht zu laut.
Da übrigens, wenn man sich so die Kommentare zu unseren letzten Sendungen anschaut, dann kommt ja dann immer wieder dieses, wir haben ja keine Ahnung.
Ist ja auch so.
Wir quatschen doch nur so scheiße, um die Leute anzuregen, sich selber zu informieren.
Genau, und ich tu das ja auch selber, und da ich auch seit längerem schon da auch in andere Podcasts reinhöre, um zumindest mal Halbwegsplan zu haben, wollte ich jetzt hier auch mal, weil das einfach mal ansteht, mal ein paar Podcast-Tipps weiterreichen. Viele von euch werden das wahrscheinlich alles schon kennen, aber vielleicht eben auch nicht. In Deutschland gibt es meiner Meinung nach zwei Podcasts, die man jetzt auf jeden Fall nennen muss. Vielleicht gibt es noch weitere, die ich nicht kenne, die sich mit Elektromobilität, insbesondere halt mit Autos, eben nicht nur beschäftigen, nämlich einerseits cleanelectric.de, die auch immer fleißig über unseren Kenntnisstand herziehen, das soll ich euch gegönnt. Und der andere Podcast ist Electrify BW aus Baden-Württemberg, unter anderem mit Jana Höfner, die als die Zoe-Pionierin in der Szene ohnehin relativ bekannt zu sein scheint. Zoe, na das bezieht sich auf den René. René?
René Zoe.
Ach so.
René, Kreatör der Automobil.
Oder René, Kremateur der Automobil. War ja ein Foto oder ein Bild im Internet, als hier die Autos angezündet wurden.
So, aber jetzt war das ausreichend verständlich. Ja, so, Leute, die auch Elektroautos fahren und damit natürlich viel mehr Ahnung haben. Aber wir haben ja Clemens und der wird uns hier demnächst wahrscheinlich sowieso mit seinen Erkenntnissen, seinen neuen Einseifen, mit seinem neuen geilen Gogomobil. Nur ist er jetzt gerade auf Testfahrt in Schweden und wird uns danach wieder erzählen, wie geil man da Internet kriegt und wie geil man da irgendwie Tesla fahren kann. Naja, und Strom schnoren kann. Der holt sich das jetzt wahrscheinlich direkt aus dem Wind. Der hat wahrscheinlich schon längst eine Windturbine oben auf seinem Tesla draufgemacht.
Das macht nicht so Sinn.
Ja, und fährt fast durch die Gegend.
Doch, wenn es parkt, macht es Sinn. Ein bisschen mehr über Technik reden?
Wir reden doch die ganze Zeit über Technik. Wir reden über uns. Wir sind ja auch kein, wir sind überhaupt nicht so ein Podcast, von dem immer alle meinen, dass wir das wären. Aber wir können jetzt mal wieder, wir können jetzt mal unser Lieblingssegment aufmachen. Was meinst du? Ja, das ist doch das Beste. So, unser Lieblingssegment Pimp my Mac. Hier ist es wieder.
Wir haben heute mal richtig Hardcore gepimpt.
Wir haben so richtig geil, krass gepimpt. Wir haben unsere Goldkettchen angelegt. Aber richtig die dicken Klotten. Zigarre rausgeholt hier.
Fuchsschwanz, Ohrringer angelegt. Das war ein Fest.
Denis hatte ja, war ja so, war ja so, ähm... war ja so nett, mir Prozessoren zu organisieren, von denen wir hier schon ein paar Mal gesprochen haben.
Ja, noch mal vielen Dank an den edlen Spender, der ja nicht ich war. Der kommt ja von woanders.
Genau, du hast nur vermittelt.
Es war nur man in the middle.
Genau, also von daher, danke an man at the end. At the beginning.
Man in the castle. Ach nee, das war was anderes.
Genau, und ganz konkret handelte es sich, um das hier noch mal in Erinnerung zu rufen, um einen Intel Xeon X5680, genauer zwei davon, weil ich hab ja noch so einen ollen Power... Es gab auch Single Core.
Ja, ich hab die Single Version, du hast die Dual Version.
Und ich hab Dual, genau.
Ich hab auch Single.
Und, genau, und vorher hatte ich einen...
Nicht Single und Dual Core, sondern Single und Dual Slot. Weil Cores sind innerhalb der CPU, Slots sind die CPU selbst, genau.
Genau, also Dual CPU und jeder... Jede CPU hat natürlich noch mehrere Cores. Und das Modell, was ich halt vorher hatte, hatte halt vier Kerne. Und der neue hatte halt sechs. Und auch die Basisfrequenz geht hier von 2,2 auf 3,3 GHz hoch. Also da war schon noch so einiges an Hub zu erwarten. Und das eigentliche Problem war ja, das Ding da reinzukriegen. Und da hast du ja angefangen zu erzählen, dass man bei dem alten Mac Pro von 2009, den ich habe, also Mac Pro 4,1, wie das so schön heißt, bei Apple, durchaus die Möglichkeit hat, da auch noch nachzulegen. Aber, dass man halt die CPUs, die man normalerweise mit Kühlkörper aufgeklebt kauft, eben...
Nee, nee, nee, der Heat-Spreader.
Das heißt, das ist nicht der Kühl... Der Heat-Spreader, der Wärmeverteiler, der da aufgeklebt ist. Entschuldigung, ich bin irgendwie...
Von dem aus wird er erst richtig gekühlt.
In der Pimper-Szene noch nicht so richtig.
Nee, Wärmespreizer.
Der Wärmespreizer.
Oder Hitzespreizer.
Hitzespreizer.
Spreiz die Hitze. Auf jeden Fall.
Vergrößert auf jeden Fall die Kontaktfläche zum Wärme ableiten. So kann man mal das zusammenführen.
Und weil das ja immer so eine Sache ist, wenn man irgendwas noch nicht gemacht hat, dann hat man ja erstmal Angst.
Ja, ich nicht so, weil war ja dein Rechner.
Oder sagen wir mal, Angst ist vielleicht das falsche Wort. Liebe Kinder, ihr sollt nie Angst haben, ihr sollt Respekt haben. Das ist eh besser. So, wie ist dann weitergegangen?
Man muss auf jeden Fall diesen Heat-Spreader runterkriegen von dieser CPU, weil Apple da noch welche ohne verbaut hat. Und man kann die halt nicht ohne kaufen oder bekommen. Und die, die ich halt, die wir hier gesponsert bekommen haben, die hatten aber einen drauf und der musste da runter. Und bei den kleinen CPUs, die nicht so, die dollen sind, da ist ja nur mit Wärmeleitpasta und mit so ein bisschen Gummi-Zeugs da festgeklebt außen drumrum. Aber bei den dickeren, so wie der Tim jetzt hier hat, ist das noch mit so einem Lötzeugs irgendwie verlötet, was so sich bei 80, 90 Grad wohl flüssig wird. Also nicht ganz so Hardcore-Löt-mäßig, aber so ein bisschen. Und das Ding musste da runter. Und dann hat Timme...
Wie ich das immer mache, Papillon gefragt. Der Mann fürs Grobe, aber auch fürs Feine. Papillon hat dann auch ein kleines Video gemacht. Und hat im Prinzip genau das so gemacht. Also einen Schraubstock eingespannt. An der Stelle auch nochmal Dank an...
An den Schraubstock?
Dank an Roxxdesign aus dem Mitteribene Slack, der nämlich ein paar Tage vorher auch nochmal dieselbe Prozedur gemacht hat und auch entsprechende Fotos von der ganzen Prozedur fotografiert hat und damit auch nochmal klar gemacht hat, dass das irgendwie alles gar nicht so schwierig ist. Und ja, der Trick ist vor allem, dass man das Ding halt richtig einklemmt. So dass man auf der einen Seite quasi den Schraubstock so an die Seite des Prozessor... Das eigentliche? Ja, auf der einen Seite der Heatspreader, auf der anderen Seite des Boards. Man den sozusagen dadurch runtertrennt. Und dann kann man das einfach so machen, aber besser ist es, wenn man es vorher nochmal warm macht. Das Papillon ist einfach nochmal mit so einem Bunsenbrenner rangegangen und hat das Ding so... so eine Minute ein bisschen angehitzt, bis es irgendwie so gefühlt irgendwo in diesem Temperaturbereich war. Und dann Schraubsfinger angezogen, dann macht es klacken wir ab. Da muss man dann noch irgendwie mit dem Messerchen nochmal rangehen und den Rest da so runterkratzen. Und dann habe ich das irgendwie nochmal mit ein bisschen Alkohol richtig schön glatt gemacht, bis er so richtig wieder shiny shiny war.
Genau, und unser Tipp für dieses Gummi drumrum abzumachen, ist entweder das iFixit, diese blauen Plasteschaber, die da sind. Die machen sich prima. Oder wer ordentlich Fingernagel hat, einfach damit. Skalpell oder Metall sollte man möglichst vermeiden.
Ja, ist ein bisschen...
So ein Teigschaber vielleicht?
Ja, alles was so Plastik und...
Ja, aber ein Teigschaber hat nicht so eine scharfe Kante. Also in diesem iFixit-Set gibt es halt so richtig diese Dinger, die sich so um irgendwas aufzuhebeln, um so Gehäuse aufzuhebeln.
Ah, die Dinger, ja.
Die haben so eine relativ feste, spitze Plastikante. Genau, genau. Und damit kannst du das wirklich super runterschaben. Und dann ist halt auch dieser äußere Gummiring weg. Der muss nämlich weg. Weil wenn du die CPU dann einlegst, dann geht es nicht nur darum, dass der große Kühlkörper, jetzt ist wirklich der Kühlkörper, über diese neue aufgetragene Hitzepaste dann nicht... also Kontakt mit dem Dye bekommt, sondern es gibt dann noch so einen Metallring, der das ganze stabil hält, der noch draufgelegt wird, und der wäre dann...
Das war Plastik.
Sicher? Nee, ich glaube, das war aus Metall, das Ding.
Nee, Plastik. Da ist ja lauter Kontakte, die Kondensatoren oder Widerstände, die da gelöst sind. Das könnte nicht aus Metall sein, das würde ja leiten. Das war Plastik.
Aber das hat doch Clear gemacht. Sicher?
Ganz sicher.
Ist egal.
Wir machen noch mal auf.
Naja, auf jeden Fall haben wir das heute hier kurz vor der Sendung. Wir haben es gemacht und ja, reingetan.
Wir haben um 10, 10 nach 5 oder 15 nach 5 angefangen und schon kurz vor 6 waren wir fertig, oder? Also es ging eigentlich.
Du hast kurz vor der Sendung vom Produktionsrechner die CPUs getauscht.
Aber...
Jaja, Bedenken haben, Respekt haben und dann jemand anders machen lassen.
Ja, aber...
Hattest du auch Backup eigentlich?
Aber Tim, du hattest auch extra noch so einen Abspreizer des Spreizers gekauft. Also so ein Tool.
Das war ein Griff ins Klo, weil der nur für neuere CPUs gedacht war und für diese CPU schlicht zu klein war.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt hier so einen Overclocker unter unseren Hörern haben, der so eine aktuelle CPU irgendwie vom Heatspreader befreien will, dann hättest du das Gerät dafür.
Genau, dann hätte ich so einen Teil jetzt irgendwie gut lieferbar.
Kommt ja vielleicht in ein paar Jahren, wer weiß. Brauchen wir das noch mal irgendwann.
Ja, mal gucken.
Jedenfalls haben wir dann gebootet. Dann war so ein bisschen ein paar Sekunden Spannung. Weil die Platten fahren natürlich immer hoch, auch wenn die CPUs so im Arsch sind und alles andere, Lüfter und so geht hoch. Und dann meinte ich, wenn der Sound kommt, dann ist alles gut, dann dauert das und das dauert und der Bildschirm war noch schwarz. Und dann kam der Sound und dann so, yeah.
Genau, und dann muss man nochmal booten und irgendwie P-RAM Reset machen, weil wenn man das macht, dann erkennt nämlich die neue CPU auch das RAM neu. Und dann läuft auch noch das RAM schneller, weil die neue CPU halt schneller aufs RAM zugreifen kann. Und jetzt habe ich schon mehr Core, mehr Gigahertz, mehr Busbreite, mehr RAM-Bandbreite.
Busbreite ist ja gleich, oder?
Also Busbandbreite, diese interne ist nicht viel, aber ist nochmal ein bisschen was.
Und hast AES-Native, also hier AES-NX, oder wie es heißt.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt 5 Volt anschalten.
Ohne Nachteile, korrekt, oder auch SSH, glaube ich, wird eventuell schon beschleunigt, weiß ich gar nicht so genau. Ich glaube aber schon.
Ja, es gibt auf jeden Fall.
Und du hast bessere Energieeffizienz, weil das ja mit dieser kleineren Struktur, das ist ja nur noch 33 Nanometer anstatt 45 oder so etwas.
Da stand doch auch 32 statt 45.
32 statt 45, ja. Also das sollte auch noch was bringen.
Ja, also alles schön und hat funktioniert. Und jetzt ist mein Rechner ziemlich ausgepimpt.
Aber da steht ja auch Verlustleistung bei dem alten 80, weil bei dem 930 Watt.
Oh ja, der Rechner muss jetzt deutlich mehr coolen, wenn er denn alle 12 Cores jetzt volle Pulle gleichzeitig ausnutzt. Aber insgesamt für die gleiche Workload, die er früher hatte, wird das jetzt weniger Strom verbrauchen. Und ich denke mal, wenn man sich die Kühlung von dem Mac Pro anguckt, der ist schon ganz schön overcooled. Also man kriegt den ja fast nicht so wirklich dazu, dass überhaupt der Lüfter mal anspringt. Also da gibt es ja auch ganz viele Leute, die denken, der Mac Pro, der kühlt nicht richtig, weil der Lüfter geht nie hoch und haben dann alle schon so Tools, dass der früher hochgeht, aber eigentlich ist das unnötig, weil das so eine Monsterkühlkörper sind, dass man da eigentlich, das ist so geil gekühlt.
Aber was ist jetzt mit deinem Tool, mit deinem Lüfter-Ansteuerungs-Tool?
Ja, das ist eigentlich auch übertrieben. Das ist nur so, weil am Ende ist es schon besser, aber eigentlich unnötig. Weil zum Beispiel, wenn du unter Bootcamp, unter Windows bist, hast du ja dieses Tool nicht. Dann bin ich auch am zocken, da kommt der Lüfter auch nicht hoch. Der macht auch das die ganze Zeit, kriegt er da die volle Breitseite an Temperatur. Bisher kein Problem. Und Speed hat sich jetzt bei Timme so rein von einer Theorie, haben wir mal durchgerechnet, von insgesamt 18 Gigahertz, wenn man 8 Cores mal 2,2 Gigahertz nimmt, ist so 18 Gigahertz. Und das Neue war irgendwie jetzt 12 mal 3,3, war irgendwas mit 41 oder so, glaube ich. Also hat sich in der Theorie mehr als verdoppelt, aber nur, wenn man wirklich alle Cores nutzen kann, was ja nicht immer der Fall ist.
Ja, ich denke, der reale Speed-Gewinn wird sich sicherlich in Grenzen halten, aber mir ging es auch darum, gerade in Peak-Belastungen, gerade hier so rausrendern, umrechnen und so weiter, was ich bei der Podcast-Produktion mache. Da einfach noch ein bisschen mehr, aber es flutscht einfach besser. Ich hab das schon beim Booten gemerkt, wie er sich eingeloggt hat. Das zog einfach alles schneller hoch.
Ja, und die Single-Straight-Performance ist ja auch besser, ist ja um 50% höher deine Gigahertz-Rate jetzt. Das sollte schon was ausmachen.
Ich bin so gepimpt jetzt.
Ja, musst du ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ich laufe jetzt nur noch breitbeinig durchs Internet.
Weil zwischen deinen Beinen der Mac Pro steht.
Einfach. Und zwar quer.
Und lüftet.
Unser Mac Pro wird ewig weiter leben.
Jetzt kann ich auch fast gar nichts mehr reinmachen. Also ich hab jetzt alles voll. Ich hab alle Slots voll durchgespielt.
Ich hab die Slots voll doch.
Wird schwierig, wenn man schon alles hat.
Ja. Na wenn man alles hat, weiß doch.
Dann brauchen wir einen neuen. Was ist das nächste Spielzeug her?
Ich bin immer noch sehr zufrieden mit meinem Gerätepark. Und mir kommt dieser neue Scheiß halt nicht ins Haus. Also ich bin ja sehr gespannt, ob...
Welcher neue Scheiß?
Na, was es auch immer gäbe. Also wenn du mir jetzt alle meine Geräte hier wegnehmen würdest...
Würde mir ganz schön scheiße da stehen.
Ich müsste sozusagen meinen Rechnerpark hier wieder beschaffen.
Aus aktuellen Quellen beziehen?
Da müssten wir auf Ebay gehen, ne?
Das wäre schwierig, ja.
Ich würde mir die ganze Scheiße wieder auf Ebay kaufen. Ich würde mir keinen neuen Max kaufen, auf keinen Fall.
Aber ein echter Pro ist ja versprochen.
Ja, aber da habe ich halt noch ein bisschen meine Zweifel. Also der wird erstmal keine korrekte Tastatur haben, aber das ist vielleicht ja noch ein lösbares Problem.
Da gehen ja weiter in die Alten ran. Das ist ja hoffentlich mit Kabel irgendwie zu machen wohl, oder?
Genau, es ist gut, dass es modular ist.
Der neue iMac Pro, der neue iMac, die haben ja auch noch altes USB.
Ob das aber nächstes Jahr auch noch der Fall ist?
Ich glaube, da haben sie einstecken müssen. Das haben sie, glaube ich, gelernt, die Lektion.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, was das...
Na ja, ich bin skeptisch.
Skeptisch bin ich auch, aber ich bin auch gespannt.
Aber selbst wenn der kommt, das ist ja... Ich meine, ich habe ja den Mac Pro auch... Also okay, ich habe den eh für richtig günstig bekommen, könnte man mal so sagen. Aber wenn ich den jetzt holen müsste oder holen wollen würde, also das Ding, was kostet wieder 3.000, 4.000 Euro Einstiegspreis nächstes Jahr? Und dann kriegst du so eine ganz kleine Mikro-Version da. Das wäre einfach nicht meine Preisliga für meine... Also das brauch ich einfach nicht. Ich bin sozusagen so ein Gebraucht-Einsteiger für später.
Naja, aber das meinte ich ja schon mal. Also die sollen jetzt einen schönen, modularen Mac Pro rausbringen, damit dann in fünf Jahren, wenn unsere jetzigen Mac Pros wirklich ausgespielt sind...
Wenn es dann kein Flash mehr geben wird, dann können wir...
Dann können wir sozusagen wieder mit den...
Ja, dann können wir wieder einsteigen und uns die bei eBay wegfischen und vielleicht nochmal nachpimpen. Und auch nur dann. Wenn man die nicht pimpen kann, dann braucht man die auch nicht mehr holen, weil dann sind die ja veraltet, also... Ja, und dein Ding ist jetzt auch schneller als der neue Mac Pro, der von... Ja, man kam ja aus 2013, war da wirklich schon 2013, meine Fresse. Aber der hat auf jeden Fall jetzt nicht so viel Bums wie deiner, ne?
Ernsthaft?
Also, wenn man jetzt bei Geekbench guckt, ist so, dass in der Konfiguration ist das wirklich das Top-Gerät. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, aber ich denke schon, ich guck das mal nach.
Weißt du Mac Pro, wa? Korrekt in der Metaebene.
Aber Grafik-Performance ist wahrscheinlich nicht besser, oder?
Mit der 280x weiß ich gar nicht so genau. Ich glaube...
Mit der CPU?
Ich glaube schon, aber da sind ja zwei Karten drin, deswegen weiß ich nicht so genau.
Versus Papiercontainer.
Hier kommt gerade die Frage, ob ich auch PCIe-SSDs habe. Also... Jein. Hatte ich ja hier schon mal erzählt. Also ich habe eine PCIe-Karte, aber die adaptiert halt zur Festplatte noch mit SATA. Und diese NVMe-Geschichte, das könnte sich halt ändern jetzt mit High Sierra. Da gibt es ja Treiber für NVMe, aber booten kann man dann davon nicht. Aber man könnte sozusagen größere zusätzliche Platten halt dann tatsächlich mit aktuellen NVMe-Karten bestücken. Da muss man noch mal schauen, wie da die Preise sinken. Derzeit habe ich halt für Bike Storage wie alle einfach Festplatten drin und nicht SSDs, aber wäre natürlich auch so für die Zukunft eine Option.
Hier bei Geekbench ist der schnellste Mac tatsächlich so ein neuer Mac Pro, diese Tonne also, mit 24.800 Punkten, also jetzt hier bei Multicore Speed, nicht bei Single-Core. Und der schnellste Mac Pro, so wie deiner, mit 12 Cores, der ist aber hier nur mit 3,1 Gigahertz, der kommt auf 18.600. Also denke ich mal auch, mit einem 3,3 Gigahertz kommt der so in Richtung 20.000. Das heißt, die runde Tonne ist halt doch mit ihren 12 Cores, mit einer moderneren CPU, deutlich schneller.
Scheiß drauf.
Ist halt so.
Die ist aber auch...
Die hat Spoiler ran geklebt.
Ist der ganze Grund.
Ja, Spoiler. Ist einfach nur die Aerodynamik.
Das war ja, ich meine, ist da der Mac Pro ohne das Upgrade, was sie kürzlich gemacht haben, auch noch dabei in dem Geekbench? Die haben noch jetzt bei dem... Die haben noch vor kurzem nochmal den Mac Pro, oder haben sie das überhaupt noch nicht gemacht? Sie haben noch gesagt... Sie haben ihn noch gespeedbumped, ist da noch der?
Das weiß ich nicht. Hier steht Late 2013, ich weiß nicht, hier sind...
Der ist dann wahrscheinlich weiter unten.
Oder heißt der einfach so und der Speedbump ist hier nicht extra erwähnt. Ich weiß ja nicht, ob hier dieses 12-Core mit 2,7 GHz schon der Speedbump ist, das weiß ich nicht so genau. Ist egal, du bist jetzt auf jeden Fall hier in der Top-Liga dabei, du bist hier Platz 4 und deiner ist sogar schneller als der, weil der hat nur 3,1, also du bist hier locker, locker hier mit, teilst dir den dritten Platz mit dem iMac. Wobei der iMac hier nur vier Cores hat, da kann ich mir ja gar nicht vorstellen, wie der auf so eine Zahl hier kommen soll, aber gut. Du müsstest den Geekbench wahrscheinlich einfach mal da anschmeißen und dann sieht man ja das was da im Teil.
Mach ich mal am besten jetzt nicht während der Aufnahme.
Oh, so viele Kerne, da ist das egal. Nee, würde ich jetzt auch mal nicht machen.
Sehr lustig.
Let's move on. To something completely different.
Also, ne, eine Sache noch. Der aktuelle Mac Pro hat irgendwie 2,7 Gigahertz, 12 Core. Dann ist das der.
Ja, bitte. Wir müssen uns über Krypto-Geld unterhalten. Wir müssen mal wieder einen Blick wagen ins Kryptoland. Das ist nämlich parallel zur Klimakatastrophe. Das ist ja sozusagen eigentlich das andere, was dieser Gesellschaft die Beine unterm Körper wegzieht.
So CO2-mäßig meinst du?
Nein, nicht CO2-mäßig, mehr gesamtgesellschaftliche Konfusion.
Also du meinst wieder so das Nokia-Problem. Die Banken sehen es auch nicht kommen.
Nein, nicht wirtschaftlich, mehr gesamtgesellschaftlich politisch.
Verstehe. Das muss man ja erstmal noch abwarten, was sich da alles so entwickeln wird.
Ja, man muss das abwarten, aber abgesehen vom abwarten kann man ja auch einfach mal in die Zukunft blicken und schauen, was denn das alles so für Implikationen hat. Aber wir können ja vielleicht über die Zukunft reden, nachdem wir mal so die Gegenwart abkloppt haben. Da ist ja so einiges passiert. Ich weiß, deine Welt ist nur so die Bitcoin-Welt, richtig?
Ja, das ist ja schon drum herum auch ein bisschen, aber halt nicht so ganz intensiv, weil, wie sagt man, wenn man da keine Eisen im Feuer hat, dann ist das immer nicht so spannend.
Genau, also ich habe da auch keine Eisen im Feuer und ich beschäftige mich damit auch eher so en passant, aber vielleicht trotzdem mal ganz interessant, weil wir haben da glaube ich auch noch nie so richtig drüber geredet, oder? Über Ethereum?
Nee, kann ich halt auch nicht. Ich lese da unten das, was bei Heise kommt, so ein bisschen. Also du wolltest da ja über die zwei Unglücke letztens erzählen, oder?
Ja, naja, also grundsätzlich muss man ja sagen, also wenn man auf so Webseiten geht, wo man sich so Kurse anschauen kann von Kryptowährungen, da wird man ja erschlagen. Ja, also das ist ja heutzutage...
Meine Empfehlung gleich, damit die Leute live klicken können, ist coincap.io. Ich glaube, da waren so circa 700 Kryptowährungen.
Scheiße.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, aber ich glaube, es waren 700. Gibt es übrigens auch auf iOS als App, sehr praktisch.
Ja, und das ist auch ganz interessant, weil hier siehst du nämlich als erste Spalte, die bei Default auch die Sortierungsspalte ist, die sozusagen angibt, wie groß sozusagen der Impact ist auf den Markt. Also Market Cap, also ausgegebene oder in Besitz gehaltene Währungseinheiten mal aktueller Umrechnungskurs zu Dollar. Und da ist auf Platz eins, ohne Überraschung, Bitcoin, aber auf Platz zwei, also mit derzeit 40, was ist das? 14 Milliarden Bitcoin, echt so wenig?
Nee, 40 Milliarden Dollar.
Äh, meine ich auch, Entschuldigung. Sind es Milliarden? Ja, es sind Milliarden. Nur?
Na nur ist gut.
Na überrasch mich jetzt schon fast. Also ich find's geradezu wenig, aber egal. Nehmen wir das mal so zur Kenntnis. Also ungefähr 40 Milliarden US-Dollar Bitcoin-Wert da draußen. 18 Milliarden dahinter Ethereum bzw. Ether ist ja die eigentliche Währung.
Ich weiß immer nicht, welches von beiden das welches ist.
Also Ether, also Bitcoin ist ja quasi die Blockchain und das einzige Produkt, was es da gibt, ist quasi die Währung Bitcoin. Na ja, noch. Ja, noch, aber wesentlich ist es so. Innerhalb der Ethereum-Welt, was quasi schon so ein Ökosystem ist, gibt es halt im Prinzip drei Dinge. Es gibt halt das, was da in die Blockchain eingetragen wird. Oder, nicht falsch erklärt. Also es gibt Geld, das heißt Ether. Dann gibt es eine Energie, die heißt Gas. Und dann gibt es halt diese Contracts. Smart Contracts. Was im Prinzip nichts anderes ist als Running Code. Beziehungsweise zunächst einmal ist es nur Code. Und um diesen Code auszuführen in dieser Blockchain, brauchst du Gas, was du dir halt mit Ether kaufen musst. Das ist quasi nochmal eine andere Denke. Und das bedeutet, du kannst halt irgendwie Verträge abschließen unter Entitäten, die mehr oder weniger mathematisch klar beweisbar eben das Eintreffen irgendwelcher Bedingungen definiert oder darauf reagiert. Auch noch ganz gut unterwegs ist Ripple. Habe ich noch nie angefasst. 6 Milliarden Litecoin, lustigerweise auch schon mit 2 Milliarden. Das war ja mal so der erste Ansatz nach.
Das war der erste Altcoin damals, den gab es ja schon mindestens zwei Jahre. 2011 als ich eingestiegen bei Bitcoin gab es glaube ich auch schon Litecoins.
Wo halt relativ, wo so ein bisschen Rechenkomplexität rausgenommen wurde, dass man das irgendwie schneller berechnen konnte, ne?
Ne, die haben einfach einen anderen, also dieses Proof-of-Work-Algorithmus ist ja bei Bitcoin so ein zweimal Schard 256 hintereinander und die bei Litecoin, die wollten das halt eben nicht. Die Leute, die schon mit den FPGAs oder Grafikkarten und später mit den ASICs, die wollten einfach einen anderen Algorithmus haben und die haben dann S-Krypt genommen. Ich glaube, das war die Geschichte und ich weiß nicht, ob sie noch andere Änderungen haben in kürzere Zeiten oder so. Weiß nicht genau, jedenfalls kannst du mit einem ASIC, der für Bitcoin schönen Mining macht, den kannst du nicht für Litecoin benutzen. Das geht nicht.
Ja, die Liste geht dann noch weiter mit ein paar anderen Sachen, die ich nicht kenne. Ehrlich gesagt, hier Dash und NEMM, schon mal gehört, aber kann ich gerade nicht richtig zuordnen. Dann gibt es nochmal Ethereum Classic. Bei Ethereum hat ja schon durch den Softwarefehler den ersten Split durch.
Das war kein indirekt Softwarefehler. Es war ein Compilerfehler, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Der Code war richtig, aber der Compiler hat falschen Code. Das gibt es nämlich zwei Compiler wohl. Und der eine hat das nicht richtig kompiliert. Wenn ich jetzt nicht ganz daneben liege, aber es war irgendwas mit Compiler. Und dann ging ja diese, wie viele Millionen waren das? Ich weiß, es war ganz schön viel. Dieser DAO war das, das war letztes Jahr. Das ging irgendwie schief. Da ging eine Menge Geld verloren deswegen. Und dann haben sich manche zusammengeschlossen und haben gesagt, ja, das finden wir gar nicht gut und wir machen jetzt mal so eine Art Rollback auf einen alten Stand, sodass die Leute ihre ISAs noch haben. Und das fanden aber nicht alle bei Ethereum gut oder von dem... Von dieser Community. Und dann haben sie sich halt getrennt. Und das, was sich da aber abgetrennt hat, von dem eigentlichen Ethereum, das nennt sich jetzt Ethereum Classic. Und da ist die Einheit auch nicht ETH, wie bei dem Ethereum, sondern ETC, weil es ja Ethereum Classic ist. Und das gibt es jetzt sozusagen, die haben sich gefolgt letztes Jahr. So könnte man das sagen.
Und ist immer noch auf Platz 7 mit 1,3 Milliarden.
Ist immer noch ganz schön am Start, ja.
Also die Classic sind die, die nicht so gerollweckt haben?
Doch, das sind die, die gerollweckt haben. Genau, habe ich auch erst nicht verstanden, aber die sind sozusagen bei Classic geblieben, wie auch immer. Das ist nicht falsch, aber bevor ihr da immer investiert, na, ihr lest nochmal nach, ist alles ohne Gewehr, hier geht es um viel Geld, teilweise nehme ich um euers. Und deswegen, ich nehme überhaupt gar keine Gewehr. Das heißt, wenn ihr euch irgendwann beschwert bei mir, dann lache ich euch aus und sage, ich hab's euch gesagt.
Ja, ich glaube, ich habe dich jetzt gerade so verstanden, dass du sagst, also ETC sind die, die keine Änderungen haben wollten.
Die, die jetzt so viel wert sind, das sind die, die geradeaus weitergemacht haben. Und die, die die Classic sind, das sind die, die sich abgespalten haben. So habe ich es verstanden letztens. Würde auch vom Preis irgendwie Sinn machen, sonst... Ich bin mir, wie gesagt, ich bin mir nicht 100% sicher. Da guck dir doch mal selber nach.
Darum soll es ja auch nicht gehen. Aber grundsätzlich, Ethereum ist schon so ein Ort, wo eine ganze Menge Probleme existieren. Und vor allem ist es der Ort, wo so die nächste fette Blase, ja, jetzt stattgefunden hat, mit diesen sogenannten ICOs. Genau. Und das ist im Prinzip so das Analogon zu den ICOs, also den Initial Public Offerings, also wenn jemand an der Börse Aktien ausgibt und sagt, hier, wir sind ein geiles Unternehmen, ihr investiert in uns, kauft unsere Aktien und die Kohle, die wir darüber einnehmen, die ist quasi die Kohle, mit der wir unser Unternehmen jetzt voranbringen.
Also was ich zum Beispiel in der letzten Sendung erzählt hab, dieses Byteball Zeugs, die ihre Byteballs einfach so an Leute ausschütten, das ist auch ein ICO, aber halt ein bisschen auf eine besondere Art und Weise, Vollmund und Tralala und so. Und dann gibt es aber auch lauter andere ICOs, aber ich weiß nicht, ob du das heute auch gelesen hast, das war gerade heute, die SEC Stock Exchange, war doch immer, wie heißt das? Was ist eigentlich die SEC?
Das ist die Commission, die halt die Security für den Aufsichtsbehörde, für den Aktienhandel macht.
Und die haben heute schon gesagt.
Das sind irgendwelche windigen Buden, die eigentlich nichts vorzuweisen haben, als das nächste verstörte Hipster-Dokument. Die haben dann auf einmal so 17 Milliarden US-Dollar umgerechnet, also in aktuellen Kryptobedeutungswolken eingenommen. Und das ganze lief halt komplett aus der Hand. Und vor allem ist da gerade was richtig Geiles schiefgegangen, eine Bude hat so ein ICO gestartet und hat gesagt, hier ist unsere Adresse, gib uns Geld.
Coin Dash war das, glaube ich, oder? Eine israelische Bude. Und genau, die haben gesagt, ja, willst du?
Ja, mach du mal, du hast es, glaube ich, noch genauer angeschaut.
Na, nicht so ganz genau, aber das reicht. Man muss ja gar nicht so viel wissen, ist ja witzig genug. Die haben gesagt, wir machen ICO und wir publishen irgendwann hier unsere Adresse und ihr könnt dann da irgendwie auf diese Adresse Geld einzahlen, also so eine Cryptocurrency-Adresse. Weiß gar nicht, ob das dann auch Bitcoin ist eigentlich oder wie das war. Nee, das war auch Ethereum. Und dann haben die Leute da innerhalb von drei Minuten wohl irgendwie die ganzen Investoren fett Geld eingezahlt. Der Witz ist nur, dass vorher so ein Hacker da war und hat da seine eigene Adresse hingeklebt. In diesen drei Minuten wohl war das das mit den 30 Millionen Dollar? Das war das, oder was? Wir hatten noch einen zweiten Unfall nur mit 8 Millionen Dollar.
Nee, hier war es von 7,6 Millionen die Rede.
Okay, dann ist das die kleinere Summe. Das ist dann mit den 30.000. Jedenfalls haben die in diesen drei Minuten diese 8 Millionen Dollar in ISA's reingespült auf die Adresse des Hackers. Wenn man dann noch weitergelesen hat später, die haben das dann auch schon runtergenommen und geändert und wollen deren Investitionen trotzdem akzeptieren und den Verlust auslegen, weil es war ja deren Fehler und nicht der der Investoren. Aber es haben wohl auch, nachdem die gesagt haben, ihr zahlt nicht mal eine falsche Adresse, kümmert euch nochmal, dass das wirklich alles stimmt und hier und da und so fort. Noch zwei Tage später kamen wohl auf dieser falschen Adresse haben Leute immer noch eingezahlt, weil sie sich das nur aufgeschrieben haben und mussten dann noch zwei Tage Geld besorgen und haben dann erst auf die Hackeradresse eingezahlt. Also zwei Tage später. Und ja, das kann man mal sehen, das ist wirklich der wilde Westen da draußen, wo alle nur noch irgendwie die Dollarzeichen im Auge sehen und sich um gar nichts mehr kümmern. Ja, aber so geht es natürlich nicht. So, das war jedenfalls der 8-Million-Dollar-Unfall oder 7,6-Million-Dollar-Unfall. Müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, da kommt so ein Krypt-Kitty, nicht so unwahrscheinlich, dass der keine 20 ist, wer weiß, ja, ändert eine einzige Adresse und hat jetzt für 7,6-Million-Dollar-Isas auf seinem Konto.
Wahrscheinlich für so einen blöden PHP-Hack irgendwie.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist der erstmal mit deinem Bürostuhl oder was auch immer, der hat nach hinten umgefallen und ist noch bis jetzt gar nicht aufgemacht. Der schwebt wahrscheinlich immer noch. So, dann der zweite Unfall. War das auch Ethereum?
Ist das diese...
Mit der Wallet, wo die einen Fehler...
Maiza-Wallet.
Genau, wo Maiza-Wallet einen Fehler in ihrer Wallet-Software hatte.
War das wirklich ein Fehler oder war das nicht hier so ein Scam? Das ist so eine Phishing-Geschichte hier. Du meinst wahrscheinlich noch was anderes, oder?
Ich meine diesen 30 Millionen Dollar Unfall oder 28 oder sowas. Ich glaube, das war schon diese Wallet, wo sie den Leuten das Geld von den Wallets runtergezogen haben.
Ja, aber das war nur ein Scam. Das war mehr so der nigerianische Prinz in Kryptogeld.
Echt? Weil die irgendwie...
Also es gibt da verschiedene Fälle. Ich krieg's jetzt auch gerade alles nie mehr zusammen. Es gab auch tatsächlich einen Fall, wo tatsächlich eine Schwäche ausgeliefert wurde. Was ich damit eigentlich sagen will, ist, wir befinden uns gerade in so einer Aufhitzungsphase mit diesem ganzen Kryptogeld, wo alle total durchdrehen.
Ja, mit der Westen heißt es halt nicht nur Goldrausch, das heißt auch Lone Gun Bands, Outlaws und überhaupt Kriminelle und alles.
Genau, Duell...
Auch das, alles am Start.
Alles am Start, haben wir schon bei Mount Gox ja schon gesehen. Der Typ ist ja jetzt auch vor Gericht und hat irgendwie alles abgestritten. Da hat jetzt der Gerichtsprozess in Japan angefangen.
Ich hoffe, die kommen da mal aus der Tasche, ich kriege da noch ein bisschen was.
Ja, ich habe auch nur 6 darumliegen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass die mich jemals wieder sehen.
Ich hoffe, ich kriege 20% davon wieder, weil sie haben ja 20% wiedergefunden oder 25% sogar. Von den 800.000 Bitcoins, musst du dir mal reinziehen, 800.000 Bitcoins mal jetzt groß von 2000, das sind 1,6 Milliarden Dollar oder Euro sogar. Jedenfalls von den 800.000 Bitcoins sind ja ganz plötzlich, 20% davon sind deine. sind fast 200.000 wieder aufgetauscht, die lagen dann so plötzlich auf so einer Adresse noch rum, und dann waren 200.000 Bitcoins wieder da. Das sind 25% von diesen 800.000. Das heißt, wenn sie Anwaltskosten hier und da und Insolvenzverfahren und weiß nicht was alles, aber 1,6 Milliarden Euro ist wirklich eine Menge Geld, kann man so eine Menge bezahlen, und die Japaner sind eigentlich sehr genau bei solchen Sachen, glaube ich, sind jedenfalls locker 20% übrig und die müssen sie wieder ausschütten. Da gibt es ja auch, hast du das gemacht? Weil diese Seiten da dann deinen Anspruch angemeldet, dass du deine Coins wieder haben möchtest. Das muss man nämlich machen. Ich hab das getan.
Du hast das getan, ich hab das getan.
Ich hab das getan. Kann man auch alles nachlesen, ist alles public.
Aber ich hab es steuerlich korrekt abgeschrieben als Verlust, das hat auch schon mal geholfen.
Echt?
Aber kann man einfach als außergewöhnliche Verlust abschreiben?
Mit dem aktuellen Gegenwert, ja?
Mit dem, zumindest dem damaligen, muss man nochmal gucken, wann man das genau anrechnen kann, aber das ist auf jeden Fall steuermindernd.
Aber bei mir ist steuermäßig auch alles im grünen Bereich.
Außergewöhnliche Verluste.
Jedenfalls müsste eigentlich noch 20% von den Verlusten, die man hatte, irgendwann mal zurückkommen. Aber es ist halt die Mühlen stetig, aber langsam. Na die Mühlen malen stetig, warum nicht die Mühlen? So, aber kommen wir noch zu den positiven Sachen von den Cryptocurrencies.
Genau, zu Bitcoin, weil da hat sich ja nun auch einiges getan und auch ich dürfte ein wenig nachverstehen.
Jetzt bitte mal hier den Teleprompter, damit ich... Der Tim hat hier eine prima Grafik, die kann er ja auch gleich mal in den Chat werfen, der dann später auch in den Links verlinkt ist. Und zwar, ich hole mir jetzt noch ganz kurz aus, weil eigentlich geht es um eine Sache, also ganz grob geht es darum, dass man mehr Transaktionen in einen so einen Block rankriegt. So ein Block ist ein Megabyte groß, in einen Megabyte kriegt man keine Ahnung.
Hol mal ein bisschen weiter aus. Also Bitcoin...
Das war schon ganz weit ausgeholt.
Also wir reden jetzt irgendwie über Bitcoin, das System, in dem halt Schwächen sich entwickelt haben. Kann man das so sagen?
Ja, das erkläre ich ja gerade, weil nämlich zu wenig Transaktionen pro Sekunde, könnte man sagen, abgefeuert werden können zurzeit so 2,6, weil halt eben alle 10 Minuten im durchschnittlichen, in der Statistik halt im Durchschnitt alle 10 Minuten wird ein Block gefunden. Und dann kann man sich ja ausrechnen, das sind 600 Sekunden mal 2,6 Transactions. Also irgendwie so 1000 Transactions sind das irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, pro Block. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen wenig. So Visa und Master, die machen irgendwie so in hohen Zeiten so bis zu 2000 Transactions die Sekunde weltweit. Und da müsste Bitcoin ja eigentlich hin, wenn sie World Domination irgendwie erreichen wollen. Ist egal, 2,6 ist auf jeden Fall deutlich zu wenig, das will man erhöhen. Da gibt es verschiedene Ansätze, da streiten die sich. Die einen sagen, wir müssen die Blöcke größer machen. Die anderen sagen, nee, das skaliert nicht, wir müssen das anders machen. Und eine Idee, das anders zu machen, ist dieses sogenannte Segregated Witness. Da wird das alles ein bisschen anders gespeichert. Und dadurch kann man da so ein bisschen mehr in der Blockchain speichern, ohne dass die Blöcke so megamäßig größer werden. Und der Vorteil ist, dass Segregated Witness auch noch so ein paar dieses Transaction Malability Problem löst, wo man irgendwie so... Malability, wie auch immer. Das fixt das jedenfalls auch mit und macht dann so Sachen möglich wie Sidechains und Lightning Networks und was es da nicht so alles gibt. Das ist so ein bisschen die Grundlage für die weitere Zukunft für Bitcoin. So und dafür gibt es einen... Jetzt hab ich natürlich die Abkürzung vergessen, was das heißt. Dafür gibt es ein sogenanntes BIP, so nennen die dann immer ihre Vorschläge bei Bitcoin. Die werden auch so durchnummeriert. Das ist so ein bisschen wie so ein RFC. Nur dass das bei Bitcoin... Bitcoin Improvement Proposals heißen die. Und diese Segregated Witness ist ein BIP 141 irgendwie beschrieben. Und das ging los letztes Jahr Dezember 2016. Weil man muss ja, weil das ja so ein verteiltes System ist mit diesen Noten. Man muss ja so einen Konsens erreichen im Netz. Und kann nicht einfach so das im Klein zu aktivieren, weil das muss bei allen gleichzeitig aktiviert werden. Das heißt, das müssen auch alle Clients erstmal auf dem neuesten Stand sein, damit wir die gleiche Version haben. Das geht nicht so einfach. Deswegen dieses BIP sagt, dass wenn 95 Prozent der Blöcke in so einem 2-Wochen-Bereich, also der Bitcoin erhöht alle 2 Wochen diese Difficulty, das sind immer 2016 Blöcke. Wenn in diesen 2016 Blöcken 95 Prozent davon dieses BIP für Segregated Witness eingeschaltet haben, also sozusagen, dass sie das unterstützen werden, erst dann wird sich das 2 Wochen später aktivieren. Alle anderen, die merken, jetzt ist es wirklich aktiviert, hätten dann nochmal 2 Wochen Zeit ihre Kleinen zu updaten, weil dann wissen sie, jetzt kommt es wirklich. So, um diese 95 Prozent zu erreichen, ist aber ziemlich schwierig. Das ging dann so los, im Januar, Februar, März ging es auf 30 Prozent, und dann ist es aber stehen geblieben. Weil den Meinern, die die Blöcke erzeugen, denen hat das nicht so richtig gefallen, weil die verdienen ja gut daran, an den Transaction Gebühren, die so gestiegen sind, weil nicht genug Transaktionen in einen Block passen, dann erhöht man die Gebühren, weil dann die ohne die Gebühren einfach nicht in den Block aufgenommen werden. Das ist so ein Krieg der Gebühren gewesen. Denen hat das natürlich gefallen, und SegWit würde das ein bisschen lösen, das Problem. Und deswegen, die Meiner, die fanden SegWit halt blöd. So, dann kam so ein schlauer Bitcoin-Core-Coder her, Luke Junior war es, glaube ich. Er ist eine bekannte Figur bei denen. Der hat sich gedacht, wir tricksen die Meiner jetzt mal aus. Und hat sich BIP 146 einfallen lassen. Das ist der sogenannte User-Activated Soft Fork. Der ist genau da, wo du gerade bist. Und der besagt, also dessen Idee war, dass nicht die Meiner, sondern die User, also ich, Huckel, du, dass wir unsere Bitcoin, Roddy hat vielleicht andere Ideen, dass wir unsere Nodes so fahren, dass wir Blöcke, die dieses Segregated Witness-Bit nicht gesetzt haben, einfach ignorieren und feilen lassen, als wenn das illegal wäre. Was überhaupt?
Also unsere Wallets jetzt oder was?
Unsere Nodes, genau, das sind ja Wallets, das sind auch Wallets. Das müssen aber keine Wallets sein. Das kann ja auch ein Node ohne Wallet sein. Das kann ja auch ohne starten. Wenn du dann eine Wallet hast, ist super, aber muss gar keine Wallet sein.
Aber der Bitcoin Core fungiert auch als Node.
Genau, das ist ein Node. So, und wenn der alle Blöcke, die halt das Secret Gated Witness Bit nicht gesetzt haben, fallen lässt, dann hätte jeder Miner, der dieses nicht macht, hätte ja nachteilweise eine Blöcke werden nicht so gut verteilt. Und die Idee von, ich glaube es war Luke Junior, war jetzt, dass wenn das sehr viele User machen, dann würden die Miner sehen, ja wir hätten jetzt einen Nachteil. Wenn die alle zusammenhalten, dann wäre das egal. Dann würden die einfach weitermachen, aber irgendein Miner wird halt aus der Reihe tanzen, wird seinen Vorteil sehen, dass wenn er Segregated Witness einschaltet, dann wird sein Block besser verteilt. Und er hat den Vorteil gegenüber den anderen Minern, weil seine Blöcke kommen durch und der Rest nicht. So, und das wäre am 1. August, das ist halt in ein paar Tagen, wäre das aktiv gegangen. Also ab dann würden Blöcke weggeschmissen werden, die dieses Bit nicht gesetzt haben.
Aber dazu müssen noch alle die aktuelle Software fahren.
Nee, nicht alle, ein paar reichen ja. Reichen ja 10%, 15%, 20%, also ein paar. Es ist ja nur ein Incentive, dass die Miner denken, wenn ich dieses Bit setze, habe ich einen kleinen strategischen Vorteil gegenüber den anderen Minern. Es ist sozusagen ein Trick, die Miner gegeneinander auszuspielen. Dass einer aus der Reihe ausbricht und das macht. Und wenn der das macht, dann machen die anderen das auch, weil sie ja sonst erst recht einen Nachteil haben. So, das würde am 1. August losgehen. Und das würde sozusagen, wenn die Miner ausbrechen, dann dafür sorgen, dass mehr Blöcke halt segret wird, dass sie 95% erreicht werden und dass es sich dann aktiviert. Weil segregated witness hat nur Zeit bis 15. November, weil solange kriegst du sozusagen dieses Bit zur Verfügung gestellt und danach ist es wieder weg, weil die haben ja nur 32 Bits, oder 31 sogar nur, weil das oberste ist schon belegt. Und du musst die sozusagen so reservieren für eine gewisse Zeit, weil die wollen ja über den nächsten 100 Jahre diese Bits so für Features benutzen. Das heißt, du kriegst immer wieder Zeit, wenn du es in der Zeit nicht aktiviert kriegst, ist dein Bit wieder weg und du musst einen neuen Antrag stellen, so könnte man das sagen mit diesen Bits. Den Minern hat das aber auch nicht gefallen, dass sie da so erpresst werden. Fanden sie gar nicht gut. Und dann kam irgendeiner auf die ganz schlaue Idee, dass es ja dann noch das BIP-91, glaube ich, gibt. Das ist eigentlich, was auch sehr gegated witness aktiviert, aber drei Monate später dann auch die Blockgröße auf 2 MB erhöht. Das ist auch nicht so richtig im Code drin, sondern das ist, glaube ich, mehr so eine Absprache. Und die Miner haben sich dazu entschlossen, das jetzt mal zu starten. Und zwar war das letzte Woche Freitag oder Donnerstag, ich glaube, Donnerstagabend war es, da haben sie sich entschlossen, das zu aktivieren. Das heißt, die haben erst mal das BIP-91-Bit gesetzt. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert. Das brauchte nur drei Tage, um sich zu aktivieren, und auch nur 80%. Die wurden sonntag früh um 8 Uhr erreicht. Das heißt, BIP-91 hat sich aktiviert. Und wenn sich BIP-91 aktiviert, heißt das, dass die Miner anfangen, das segregated witness-Bit zu setzen. Was sie jetzt seit Sonntag früh machen. Und jetzt ist inzwischen das segregated witness-Bit schon auf, ja, jetzt müsste es so bei 66% sein. Also schon 20% höher als letzte Woche, weil da war es noch so bei 45%. Das heißt, die aktivieren jetzt gerade segregated witness. Segregated witness braucht aber zwei Wochen. Und bis diese 95% erreicht werden, dauert es noch eine Weile. Und ob die Miner das wirklich bis zum Ende durchziehen, ist halt noch sehr spannend. Aber sie sind sozusagen diesem User-Activated Soft Fork, der am 1. August starten würde, zuvor gekommen. Weil das wäre ja dann auch so eine Art Chainsplit. Weil wenn manche Blöcke abgewiesen werden und manche nicht, dann würden die Miner die Chain wachsen lassen ohne segregated witness mit. Und dann würde eine zweite Chain entstehen, wo die Bits aber gesetzt sind. Und so einen Chainsplit willst du halt vermeiden, weil du hast dann dein Geld teilweise ja doppelt, nämlich in beiden Chains, wenn dein Geld älter ist als der Split. Und das wird dann kompliziert. Also Splits will man auf jeden Fall vermeiden. Und das ist jetzt das spannende dran. Und dann gibt es aber jetzt noch Leute, die segregated witness wirklich, wirklich richtig blöd finden. Die sind aber glaube ich auf deiner Grafik da gar nicht dabei. Das ist so Bitcoin ABC, glaube ich, und Bitcoin Cash. Oder vielleicht ist es auch das gleiche. Da blicke ich gar nicht mehr so durch, es gibt so viele. Jedenfalls die wollen so eine Art Bitcoin auch Classic machen ohne segregated witness. Und wenn die das wirklich tun, dann wird sich die Chain auch splitten. Weil dann gibt es eine mit segregated witness und eine ohne. Und da muss man halt ein bisschen aufpassen. Diese Währung, die heißt dann nicht BTC wie bei Bitcoin, sondern BCC wie Bitcoin Classic. Das ist dann das gleiche bei Ethereum. Und da rätseln jetzt schon, wie der Preis sich ungefähr entwickeln wird. Und so weiter und so fort. Die nächste Zeit sollte man auf jeden Fall mit seinen Bitcoins die Füße stillhalten, irgendwelche Transaktionen zu machen, wenn da irgendwelche Chainsplit entstanden sind. Das ist gefährlich, weil da muss man aufpassen.
Bis wann wird sich das entschieden haben?
Also jetzt muss erst mal dieses Segglegated Witness, steht ja da bis ca. 10. August. Also wenn ihr es jetzt gerade durchzieht, dann aktiviert sich Segglegated Witness am 10. August. Aber am 1. August werden hier diese Bitcoin ABC oder Bitcoin Classic und wie die alle heißen, ich glaube da wollen die splitten, wenn die keinen Segwit irgendwie wollen, dann kann das da schon irgendwie losgehen. Kann aber auch sein, dass sich das dann erst splittet, wenn Segglegated Witness wirklich da ist, was ja am 10. August ist. Das ist mir noch nicht so klar. Das war schon ein ganz schönes Summary.
Das ist kein Management Summary, das war ein Technical Summary. Das Management Summary ist...
Ich hab schon ganz schön viele Sachen weggelassen.
Es werden, ich versuch mal so, ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob ich es komplett verstanden habe, aber kurz gesagt, verschiedene Strategien werden von der Community verfolgt. Einige waren ursprünglich nicht ganz so populär, weil sie quasi nicht unbedingt den Interessen zugespielt haben, was ich nicht so ganz verstanden habe. Dieser, ein bisschen wie so ein Friedensvertrag aussehende BIP 91, der sozusagen jetzt diese Strategien da zusammenfasst.
Das war nur ein Trick, das war so ein BIP, der schon da war, den man ausgenutzt hat, um diesen user-aktivierten Softwalk irgendwie ein bisschen zu vermeiden und die Miner auf eine Linie zu kriegen. Dass halt am 1. August nicht hier so ein Softwalk stattfindet.
Aber warum mussten da die Miner jetzt mitgehen? Das hab ich nicht verstanden.
Na ja, weil die die meisten Blöcke...
Weil die die Blöcke generieren. Also heißt, die Miner sind die, die das mitsetzen.
Nein, ich weiß, warum sie mitgehen müssen, aber warum müssen sie mit diesem BIP 91? Das können sie doch auch ignorieren.
Weil die sich eigentlich vor Monaten schon bei so einem sogenannten New York Agreement entschlossen haben, das segregated witness mit zusammen zwei Megabyte einzuführen oder irgendwie so...
Ja, aber wenn sie sich schon enttossen haben, das einzuführen, wo sie das geben.
Ja, sie haben ganz schön oft eine Menge beschlossen, aber die haben halt nie irgendwas umgesetzt. Die Miner und die Core-Developer sind nicht so auf der gleichen Linie. Und die Core-Developer schreiben den Code und sind sehr mächtig. Die Miner sind aber die, die Blöcke erzeugen und die Bits setzen und sind eigentlich auch ganz schön mächtig, was eigentlich nicht sein sollte. Und die User, komischerweise, die den Nodes fahren, sind irgendwie gar nicht so richtig mächtig, weil die den Code nicht schreiben und auch diese Bits nicht setzen. Deswegen der User-Activated-Softwalk ist so ein bisschen die Methode, den Leuten, die den Nodes fahren und die vielleicht auch die Bitcoins haben, den eigentlichen User wieder so ein bisschen Macht zurückzugeben. Aber durch so einen fiesen Trick, das ist schon so ein bisschen erpressungsmäßig. Wir lassen, wir schmeißen einfach eure Blöcke weg und ihr habt dadurch einen Nachteil und einer von euch wird aus der Reihe tanzen, wird das Bit doch setzen und dann noch mehr Nachteile und so, also man trickst die aus eigentlich.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja dann auch das Core-Team, was letzten Endes da diesen Code macht. Die User tun ja nichts.
Nee, das ist ein Patch, der Original-Client hat diesen Code nicht. Das ist ein Patch, den musst du von Hand einsetzen. Luke Junior ist zwar Core-Developer, aber der hat sozusagen mit dem Core nichts zu tun. Das ist nicht im offiziellen Bitcoin-Code drin.
Mit so einem Patch kriegen sie irgendwie 10%?
Keine Ahnung, der ist ja noch nicht erster, August. Man weiß nicht, wieviel sie geschafft hätten. Also ich hab drei Nodes am Laufen. Und vor ein paar Wochen gab es die Idee, dass selbst wenn man den Patch noch gar nicht fährt, man kann ja mit seinem User-Agent schon ankündigen, dass man es tun wird. Das heißt auch meine drei Nodes kündigen an, dass sie den User-Activated-Softfork 1.0-Patch fahren werden. Das kann man ja nicht unterscheiden, weil es wird ja erst aktiviert am ersten Morgen.
Wir müssen das noch mal ein bisschen zusammenfalten. Was denkst du denn, was wird denn jetzt passieren? Was ist denn deine Erwartung?
Das ist schwierig. Also ich hoffe, dass die Meiner halt ihr Wort halten und jetzt weiterhin dieses Bid für das Seggle Gate and Witness setzen und dass es sich am circa 10. August, oder was es da ist, die 95 Prozent erreicht werden. Dann wird zwei Wochen später Seggle Gate and Witness aktiviert und das ist dann erstmal in Sack und Tüten und geht dann auch nicht mehr weg und ist aktiv. Wenn die das nicht machen, dann glaube ich, kann man nicht so richtig vorhersagen, was von diesen ganzen Ideen da umgesetzt wird. Das ist unklar. Diese Bitcoin-ABC, die auf Classic machen wollen und ohne Segregate and Witness, ich denke, die werden veröden wie eine Wasserpflanze in der Wüste.
Ja, was heißt denn das dann? Ich meine, wenn die da ihre Bitcoins dann auf so einem alten, auf so einem abgespaltenen Ast treten, dann ist das Geld back.
Also wenn sich die Chain splittet, ja.
Dann sind ja meine Bitcoins im anderen Universum immer noch da.
Genau, aber wenn du in dem einen Universum eine Transaction machst, dann hast du das ja signiert, dass von dieser Adresse auf folgende Adresse deine Coins gehen sollen. Aber die gleiche Transaction geht ja in der anderen Chain auch. Weil es ist ja noch die gleiche Adresse, wo es herkommt. Also das wird schwierig dann. Und solange du das nicht machst, ist dein Geld in beiden verfügbar. Wenn du das anfängst zu benutzen, dann kommst du darauf an, in welche Chain du das schiebst, wie man das aber trennen soll. Weiß ich noch nicht genau. Das hat halt noch, glaube ich, nie so richtig jemand gemacht. Da wird es ein bisschen kompliziert.
Aber es ist ja relativ schnell dann eigentlich klar, wenn zum Beispiel so große Plattformen wie Coinbase, die haben sich ja auch schon positioniert, wir traden keine Hardfork-Coins zum Beispiel oder so, wenn dann irgendwelche Marketplaces oder andere Bitcoins senken, wo man tatsächlich das ausgeben kann, halt sagen, ja, das ist jetzt das, was wir als Standard akzeptieren, dann ist ja richtig schnell klar.
Ja, aber da gibt es auch ganz viele Exchanges, die schon gesagt haben, wenn das forkt, wir passen uns da an und machen das auf. Denen ist das am Ende egal, die verdienen halt an Prozenten. Denen ist es total egal, ob du da mit Scheiße handelst oder mit Bitcoins oder mit sonst was, hauptsache sie kriegen ihren Anteil. Deswegen, auf die ist sowieso kein Verlass. Deswegen, erstens, was man machen sollte vor dem 1. August, man hält seine Bitcoins eigentlich sowieso grundsätzlich nicht, aber jetzt gerade erst rechtlich, man lässt sein Geld nicht auf Exchanges liegen, sondern man packt sich das zu Hause unter das Kopfkissen. Also das Geld liegt nicht bei der Bank, sondern bei einem selber. Weil dann ist es zur Not, wenn die da einen Scheiß machen, ist es weg. Oder wenn die, egal was passiert und gerade jetzt, man will nicht, dass das Geld von jemandem anders verwaltet wird. Sondern man will das bei sich selber haben. Und dann ab 1. August bis vom Jahr aus 10. August oder bis neue Nachrichten kommen, dass alles super ist, im schlimmsten Falle nicht anfassen.
Bis zur nächsten Freak Show liegen lassen, bis denn es ein Update gibt.
Oder auf jeden Fall eine Menge News lesen, was jetzt da passiert ist. Und am 1. August gucken, was so entsteht. Und abwarten, bis die Medien kommen. Saygegated Witness ist jetzt aktiviert mit 95 Prozent. Das dauert dann nochmal zwei Wochen. Aber wenn es aktiviert ist, gibt es da kein Zurück. Also die zusätzlichen zwei Wochen sind nur noch Schonzeit für alle anderen, dass sie updaten können, weil dann geht es irgendwie los. Und ja, das ist dann ein Softfok. Weil alle alten Clients kommen mit diesen Blöcken auch klar. Ein Hardfok ist, wenn alle alten Clients mit Blöcken nicht mehr klarkommen. Und wenn du wirklich updaten musst oder sonst komplett raus bist. Das ist, wenn ein Hardfok passiert. Also wenn die zum Beispiel zwei Megabyte einführen, dann würden alle jetzigen Clients nicht mitmachen, weil das ist zu groß, die würden das automatisch wegschmeißen. Also für ein 2-Megabyte-Update muss man auf jeden Fall seinen Client updaten. Außer man hat halt schon einen, der das kann. Aber das sind diese komischen Bitcoin Unlimited und Bitcoin XL, hieß das früher und weiß ich nicht, wie sie alle heißen. Und die sind ja auch alle immer wieder verstorben. Also meine persönliche Meinung ist, die Bitcoin Core-Programmierer sind die, die da seit 5, 6, 7 Jahren teilweise da dann rumprogrammieren. Das sind die, wenn sie es kaputt machen wollten, wie viele den unterstellen, dann hätten sie es doch schon längst getan. Aber das sind die, die da sich um die Code-Qualität kümmern und wo die Innovationen herkommen, wie die neuen Adressen, was ich glaube ich vor 2 Folgen mal erzählt habe und so. Und ich vertraue denen halt am meisten und den Meinern vertraue ich eher nicht, weil das ragen nichts bei, außer das Geld absahnen.
Bitcoin meiner Kartelle, könnte man so sagen. New York Agreement.
Ja, die treffen sich auch öfter mal, wie die Zukunft von Bitcoin so aussehen soll und so. Na, da muss man mal gucken.
Meiner Kartelle abschaffen.
Wir berichten in einer nächsten Freak Show. Es wird auf jeden Fall spannend werden.
Und schnell noch irgendwie die Bitcoins ins Trockene bringen.
Naja, solange die bei dir zu Hause ist, ist alles gut. Da muss man eigentlich gar nichts machen.
Genau. Sicherheit eure Bitcoin, indem ihr sie einfach auf meinen Kopfkissen überweist.
Naja, es gibt ja auch Paper-Bitcoins, also es ist ja alles möglich. Du kannst es auch physisch unter das Kopfkissen legen.
Man kann ja auch einfach die Metaebene Spenden-Bitcoin-Adresse nehmen und es dort parken.
Dauerparkgabe.
Dauerparkplatz für Bitcoin.
Pass gut drauf auf.
Die Nies-Taste hat nicht genießt.
Hat nicht genossen.
Ansonsten auch immer ein kleines Up-to-Date-Halten. 0.14.2 ist gerade aktuell. Dann zeig mal kurz so eine Liste. War da noch irgendwas mit Bitcoin oder Kryptocurrencies? Doch, Kryptocurrencies hatten wir ja noch.
Ach doch, eine haben wir noch. Stella.
Also, erstens nochmal zurück zu den ByteBalls. Am 8. August oder 7. August ist es wieder soweit. Oder sogar der 6. Da gibt es wieder free money. Wenn man schon Bitcoins hat, kann man sich da anmelden. Kriegt man ByteBalls zugewiesen. Das ist sozusagen ein ICO, ein Initial Coin Offering based on Bitcoins. Ist halt so. Wer es noch nicht gehört, der letzte Mal, der sollte mal nachgucken. Und weil das ja noch nicht genug ist, für Leute, die schon Bitcoins haben, gibt es noch eine zweite Währung, die heißt Stella. Oder die Währung selber heißt dann, die Einheit heißt Lumens. Aber die Seite heißt stella.org. Und die schütten ihre Bitcoins auch aus. Ich glaube, die ist hauptsächlich aktiv auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent. Und die nutzt auch ganz viele Firmen, die dann diese Lumens hin und her schieben. Also ich glaube, das läuft so ein bisschen anders dort. Aber es ist auch halt so eine Mikrowährung. Und die schütten jetzt auch ihre Lumens aus an Leute, die Bitcoins haben, zu 19% und an Leute, die Ripples haben, zu 1%. Ripples habe ich jetzt keinen, deswegen kann ich da nicht sagen, wie es geht. Aber Leute, die Ripple haben, können sich das auch mal angucken. Und da kann man auch wieder, wie bei Byteball, mit so einer Signatur beweisen, wie viel Bitcoins man hat. Und dann kriegt man diese Lumens zugeschoben. Und dann hat man Lumens. Und ja, hat war auch gut. Sollte sich jeder, der Bitcoins hat, mal angucken. Und dann, damit man die zur Not auch gleich loswerden kann, habe ich auch eine gute Idee. Ja, das könnt ihr auch machen. Nee, aber es gibt eine prima Seite. Ich habe die auch benutzt und es hat funktioniert. Ich habe das mit den Lumens gemacht, weil es war nicht so viel. Und das war jetzt, ich dachte, ich mach das jetzt einfach mal. War mir nicht so wichtig. Eine Seite, die heißt change.ly.org. Also change.ly.org. Kannst ja mal testen, ob das auch die richtige ist mit der Endung hinten. L-L-Y. Nee, zwei L. Change.ly, wie auch immer man damals aussprechen soll. Oder es ist.com. Ich spreche das immer so aus. change.ly.com mit zwei L, aber Y hinten. Und dort kann man prima von einer Kryptowährung in eine andere Kryptowährung tauschen. Und man muss nichts weitermachen, außer sich mit irgendeiner E-Mail anmelden. Man kriegt da zwar ein Passwort zugesendet, aber eigentlich braucht man das erstmal noch gar nicht, solange man auf der Webseite ist. Und dann kannst du prima sagen, hier, ich hab hier 5000 Lumens. Ich hätte die gerne getauscht in, ja, in ESAs oder in Bitcoins oder in Byteballs. Ist total egal, da klickste drauf. Dann zeigt dir so ein QR-Code an, wo du halt deine Lumens hin überweisen sollst. Oder jetzt sagt dir halt, wie du das bezahlen sollst, das, was du da möchtest. Dann sagt er, okay, ist jetzt angekommen. Dann sagt er, okay, wir sind jetzt gerade an den ganzen Exchanges der Welt, dein Zeug zu verkaufen, weil die haben gar keinen eigenen Markt, sondern die machen das mit Bots bei den anderen Systemen und suchen dir den besten Preis raus. Das machen sie dann so eine Weile lang. Und dann irgendwann sagen sie, ja, hier fertig, wir haben dein Zeug jetzt alles verkauft und jetzt überweisen wir das auf die Adresse, die du vorher auch schon angegeben hast, in die Währung, in die du das halt haben wolltest. Ich wollte halt Bitcoins haben, hatte den vorher schon meine Bitcoin-Adresse geben und dann so eine Viertelstunde später hat es Ka-Ching gemacht und dann hatte ich dann irgendwie Bitcoins.
Getauscht von was?
Von den Lumens.
Die du bekommen hast?
Von dem CEO von stella.org, weil ich gesagt habe, dass ich Bitcoins habe.
Also du hast Bitcoin gemacht sozusagen.
Könnte man so sagen.
Und da hast du die Währung dann gleich wieder verlassen.
Investorenhaie.
Nicht ganz. Aber das war nicht so viele. Und ich dachte mir, ja, ich probiere das jetzt mal. Ich kannte diese Webseite auch nicht. Die wurde mir als Tipp auch empfohlen. Ich dachte, ich probiere das mal aus. Und ich muss sagen, es hat wirklich super gut funktioniert. Die Webseite ist ganz fancy. So ein bisschen modernes Zeug, aber hat alles funktioniert. Mit der E-Mail wirklich. Du meldest dich zwar mit E-Mail-Adress an. Aber sonst, das war es eigentlich. Wie gesagt, da kriegst du ein Passwort. Aber das braucht man für den ersten Vorgang da gar nicht. Du kannst da auch mehrere Vorgänge machen. Und wenn du immer auf die Seite gehst mit deinem Login, kannst du gucken, ob das jetzt angekommen ist oder nicht. Und so weiter und so fort. Und ansonsten, wer mir was Gutes tun will, der kann im Twitter meinen Link auf Change.ly suchen. Weil ich hab da auch so einen Affiliate-Link bekommen. Und den hab ich dann in Twitter geprostet. Hättest du jetzt auch machen können. Aber jetzt hast du schon verballert. Die haben auch Affiliate-Links. Dann kriegst du die Hälfte von dem, was die verdienen, und dann kriegst du dann ab. Ja, was auch immer, Bitcoins, weiß ich nicht. Bitcoins, glaub ich. Die Grundwährung ist schon Bitcoins. Ist natürlich ein bisschen fies, weil wenn die Lumens ausschütten, dann wollen die natürlich nicht, dass man die gleich wieder verhökert. Aber da gab's ja anscheinend auf dieser Welt auch irgendwer, der die Lumens für Geld haben wollte. So gesehen ist die jetzt ja auch nur von mir zu jemand anderem gerutscht. Ob ich die hab oder der andere ist ja am Ende auch egal. Aber er hat dafür den Kurs bezahlt, der halt für Lumens gerade so angesagt war. Was auch, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel das jetzt ist, aber...
Mann, das ist echt so der Wahnsinn hier.
Das ist der Wahnsinn. Sollen die mal schön so weitermachen. Ich finde das gut. Also Bitcoin-based ICOs finde ich voll schick.
Könnte ich mich dran gewöhnen. Um das kennst du vielleicht...
Das ist aber nur einmalig und die Lumens kann man jetzt noch machen bis 29. Dann ist es vorbei. Also es ist nicht so wie bei den Byteballs jeden Vollmond und so. Das ist wirklich nur eine einmalige Sache. Bis Ende August.
Ein letzter Punkt noch. Und da, wie am Anfang schon angedeutet, vielleicht mal so ein bisschen ins Philosophische reingehen, weil mir das so ein bisschen durch den Kopf gegangen ist am Wochenende. Eine Währung, die wir jetzt noch gar nicht erwähnt haben, aber die ja im Prinzip auch eine große Rolle zu spielen scheint, ist Zcash. Ich weiß nicht, ob du dir Zcash schon mal genauer angeschaut hast, aber...
Nee, könnte ich auch gar nicht glauben. Das ist noch zu komplex, als dass ich mir das anschauen könnte. Ich glaube, ich müsste warten, bis sich andere das anschauen und dann so ein Summary kriegen. Und das braucht ja mal eine Weile, bis man so richtig tief einsteigen kann und das alles so versteht. Hat mich ja bei Bitcoin auch ganz schön lange gekostet.
Was man über Zcash auf jeden Fall sagen kann, ist halt eine relativ junge Entwicklung in diesem ganzen Kryptowährungsspiel. Und sie scheinen halt ein paar Dinge zu haben, die die anderen halt nicht haben. Allen voran dieses Zero... Ja, dieses Zero... Zero Proof Trust. Irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, der Begriff ist jetzt falsch. Im Kern heißt das anonyme Überweisung. Du kannst halt eine Überweisung überprüfen, ohne dass du halt automatisch so ein pseudonymes Wert wem was gegeben im Netzwerk aufbaust wie bei Bitcoin. Und an der Stelle wird es halt haarig. Es geht wohl auch eine ganze Menge Geld in Zcash. Hier auf deinem coincap.io hat man ja gesehen, Zcash ist hier definitiv auch schon in der...
Platz 15?
Platz 15. Und auf jeden Fall ist da Musik drin. Was man jetzt vielleicht diesen Platz alleine jetzt nicht so ansieht, aber... Und klar, 300, was sind wir da jetzt? 333 Millionen US-Dollar klingt viel, wenn man es alleine hat. Ist natürlich jetzt als Markt für sich genommen nicht viel. Zumal das alles, muss man auch immer nochmal dazu sagen, das ist ja alles eine große Blase, von der man nicht weiß, wann sie an welcher Stelle wo mal platzen könnte. Kann auch alles nicht platzen, kann sein, dass manche platzen. Ich würde sogar fast sagen, von diesen Kryptowährungen, die wir hier sehen, werden die wenigsten langfristig überleben, weil das ist ja irgendwie alles der helle Wahnsinn. Also wer soll denn da noch den Überblick behalten? Und vor allem, was man ja generell sagen muss, bei diesen ganzen Blockchain-basierten Sachen, so eine Infrastruktur kann halt nur überleben, wenn es da langfristig und nachhaltig eine Community gibt, die bereit ist, dort auch zu investieren, in Terms of Mining und Transaktionen.
Ich sehe das auch immer so, der Wert von so einer Währung ist nicht nur halt, was sie in Euros Wert ist, sondern auch, was sie halt für Features hat und wie man sie halt benutzen kann. Bitcoin kann man halt ausgeben. Die hat halt irgendwie weltweit von A nach B, kannst du das schieben, ohne dass du jemanden dazwischen hast. So Zero Cash hat halt dieses Anonyme. Irgendwelche anderen Währungen haben irgendwie andere coole Sachen, so wie das Byteball mit ihren Oracles da hat und so weiter und so fort. Aber wenn so eine Währung halt keine coolen neuen Features hat oder sich nicht absetzen kann von den anderen Kryptowährungen, die es schon ein Jahr vorher gab, dann ist die halt nichts wert. Und davon gibt es halt eben, ja 1000 jetzt nicht, aber hunderte. Du bist jetzt schon hier bei 280 und das hört nicht auf. Ich glaube, ich habe mal bis zum Ende gescrollt und es waren 700 oder so.
Also jeder Idiot, der im Internet in der Lage ist, jetzt gerade irgendwie so eine Blockchain aufzusetzen, macht da irgendwie seinen Kram und es gibt da einfach genug Leute, die nur so halbgebildet sind und da irgendwie Kohle reinschmeißen, nach welchen Konzepten auch immer. Das ist natürlich, das wird alles keinen Bestand haben.
Nee, die meisten sind ja auch einfach normale Code-Kopien oder Forks einfach von Originalsoftware, damit so ein paar Parametern geändert und so, dass sie halt irgendwie die Initial Coins oder das Pre-Mining machen, dass sie erst mal für sich selber generieren und danach erst anfangen, mit denen zu handeln, obwohl sie schon irgendwie einen riesen Anteil an dieser Währung halten. Das sind alles sogenannte Scam-Coins. Guck, jetzt bist du hier aber schon bei der 750. Okay, 742 Kryptowährungen gibt es und die letzte ist auch nur noch insgesamt Market Cap 250 Dollar wert. Also das ist einfach...
Das ist halt ein Studenten-Experiment, ne?
Und auch nur das.
Die heißen auch immer Scheiße.
Pizza-Coin. Gibt es auch.
Power-Coin. Es gibt auch ein Trump-Coin. Kannst du mal nach Trump suchen? Trump-Coin. Ich glaube, Putin-Coin gab es schon vor Jahren.
Trump-Coin.
Platz 404. Sagt ja einiges.
Not found.
Ja, nochmal zurück zu Zcash. Zcash ist definitiv einer der heißeren Kandidaten für langfristigere Überlebenschancen und vor allem halt ein System, was eben anonyme Zahlungen ermöglicht. Und da geht es bei mir auch so ein bisschen auseinander, weil nehmen wir mal an, das nimmt jetzt noch zu. Und wir reden jetzt nicht von 40 Milliarden Market Capitalization in ein paar Jahren, sondern wir reden halt von irgendwie 40 Trilliarden Market Capitalization für Bitcoin oder eben auch für Zcash oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen. Wo dann vielleicht auch ein Markt entsteht und wo vor allem auch Bezahlwege entstehen, wo schon so eine eigene Wirtschaftsflow auch besteht. Deshalb hat dieser Planet nur Erfahrung mit Bezahlsystemen, wo es eine staatliche oder interstaatliche Kontrolle gibt. Es gibt Zentralbanken in den USA, Zentralbanken in Europa, es gibt halt Aufsichten etc. und es gibt eben ein Stück weit auch die Möglichkeit der Regierung und sonstiger politischer Konstellationen in dieses ganze Finanzspiel mit einzuwirken. Und vor allem gibt es halt auch die Möglichkeit, ich will jetzt hier nicht unbedingt Panik verbreiten, aber so Geldflüsse auch in gewisser Hinsicht zu überblicken und kontrollieren zu können, hat ja auch was Gutes. Wenn Steuern und andere windigen Geschäfte, die abgeschlossen werden, auf einmal auf irgendwelchen karibischen Inseln landen, vorbei an fiskalischen Entitäten, ist es halt in der Regel zum Nachteil von vielen.
Ja, aber komischerweise wird das eigentlich alles über Banken gemacht und ist eigentlich schon über geregelt Institute und trotzdem wird man da beschissen. Also es wird ja dann eher noch schlimmer mit den Coins.
Darauf will ich hinaus. Es wird alles noch viel schlimmer mit diesen Coins. Wenn du nämlich ein Bezahlsystem hast, was irgendwie komplett anonym ist, wo du zwar nachweisen kannst, dass du eine Zahlung genommen hast oder versendet hast, aber dir nicht nachgewiesen werden kann, wer du bist und dem Gegenüber nicht nachgewiesen werden kann, wo dir denn die Kohle herkommt. Naja, also das ist irgendwie...
So ein bisschen wie Kryptonachrichten, oder? Einfach nicht mehr beweisen, was da drin steht.
Es ist halt auch so ein bisschen... Doch, du kannst das beweisen. Du kannst nicht beweisen, wer daran beteiligt war, aber du weißt, dass diese Bezahlung legitim ist. Also der eigentliche Marktplatz funktioniert noch.
Für Waffen- und Drogenhändler natürlich super.
Für Waffen- und Drogenhändler total super. Und wir haben ja gesehen, was mit diesen ganzen Drogenbuden, die auf Tor aufgemacht wurden und die mit Bitcoin sich bezahlen lassen, so passiert ist. Gut, die haben teilweise technische Fehler gemacht. Jetzt wurde letzte Woche irgendwie wieder so zwei Darknet-Vertriebsplätze breitgemacht.
Alva Bay und Hansa, irgendwas, ne?
Genau. Aber die werden natürlich auch weiterziehen, beziehungsweise wenn...
Ja, die ziehen nicht weiter, den gibt es schon längst. Also es sind ja immer nur die bekanntesten, die da hops gehen. Ich glaube, die nächsten, die gab es, also man muss...
Also da gibt es überhaupt keinen Mangel an Nachschub, ne? Der Bedarf ist da und in dem Moment, wo wir halt irgendwie ein komplett anonymes Bezahlsystem haben, was halbwegs Vertrauen im Markt hat, wie zum Beispiel Zcash, wird das halt sehr schnell gehen. Und die Frage ist halt, was passiert denn dann eigentlich? Also...
Ja, und klar.
Machen wir uns da noch groß Gedanken um das Schmelzen des Polareises, wenn wir irgendwie so eine Sache abziehen, weil das ist halt... Ich hab jetzt keine Antwort darauf, aber ich will auch nur sagen, wir reden hier über Kryptowährungen, aber wir bejubeln das jetzt nicht unbedingt als die Verkündung der Zukunft.
Ich glaub auch.
Weil die Bescheisser, wenn die jetzt schon bescheißen können, indem sie halt ihr Geld in die Karibik schieben oder sonst wo, und das sowieso auch schon mit Banken oder irgendwelchen Instituten, Scheinfirmen und was weiß ich nicht alles machen. Also ich meine, es kann sein, dass es ein bisschen einfacher für die fällt, wenn dann halt die Kryptowährungen in ordentlich da sind, so Zero Cash und Konsorten, aber so richtig groß ändern. Insgesamt wird sich da, glaube ich, nichts. Es ist ja mehr für mich, dass sich was ändert, indem nämlich ich irgendwie mein Geld selber verwalte und nicht das auf der Bank liegt, so wie in Griechenland, wo man auf einmal dann Negativzinsen hat und alles, was man über 10K hat, was sich die Oma gerade zusammenspart, wird dann irgendwie mal eingezogen. Das gab es ja da ohne Ende.
Ja, in der kurzen Lange heißt das ja, dass du sozusagen kein Steuer mehr zahlen willst.
Doch, man kann ja Steuer zahlen. Man hat ja trotzdem noch Einnahmen.
Man kann Steuern zahlen, aber dir kann ja dann nicht mehr belegt werden, dass du steuerpflichtig wärst.
Ja, dann müssen die sich halt mal überlegen, worüber man, also worauf man ein Steuer nimmt und worauf nicht. Dann ändert sich das vielleicht. Dann ist das nicht mehr auf dem Besitz, den man hat, weil das man dann nicht beweisen kann, sondern dann nehmen sie halt mehr Steuern bei Sachen, wo du was ausgibst.
Ja, das sind zum Beispiel etwas, was ich auch mit Z-Cash bezahle.
Ja, aber du gehst nicht zum Autohändler und bezahlst ein Auto mit Z-Cash. Und ob du deinen Kaffee mit Z-Cash bezahlt, ist wahrscheinlich egal.
Heute nicht.
Ja, aber das kann ja nicht jeder Laden illegal werden, weil es sind ja schon auch... Nein, nein, kann nicht jeder......physikalische Sachen, die du da kaufst. Und dann muss es ja ein Geschäft für geben und einen Ort, und der muss ja auch liefern. Und das ist ja irgendwie protokollierbar. Du gehst ja irgendwo hin und sagst, und wenn die Polizei oder Steuerfahne auch mal da hinkommen und die sagen, wie sieht es denn aus mit deinen Namen? Dann sagt der, ich hatte keine Ahnahmen, ich bin seit Monaten hier und hier ist keiner gekommen. Dann sagen die, ja, alles klar. Also ganz so easy ist es ja nicht, dann zu bescheißen. Das kann nicht immer beschissen werden, das geht nicht.
Ja, aber du hast einfach 1A Geldwäsche-Basis in solchen Systemen. Das heißt, du kannst so wie die Einnahmen, die du irgendwie in dem einen illegalen Ort hast, kannst du schnell mal...
An den anderen schieben.
An den anderen schieben und...
Aber ich finde, das sind ja die gleichen Argumente, wie das Internet ist schlecht, weil da sind ja nur Drogen, Zeugs und unterwegs und so. Das haben wir jetzt enttäuscht, mit dem Mobiltelefon war das gleiche, mit Kryptos ist das gleiche und jetzt ist es das gleiche mit Kryptowährungen. Also ich finde, klar kommen da auch negative Sachen, aber wahrscheinlich auch sehr, sehr viel positive Sachen. Du musst nicht Western Union irgendwie 30 Dollar bezahlen, weil du 40 Dollar nach Australien verschicken willst.
Ja gut, aber es kann ja sein, dass ich mir etwas Komfort auf der einen Seite mit einer ganzen Menge Konsequenzen einkaufe, die ich vielleicht so nie haben wollte. Diese ganze Kryptowährungsszene mit diesen ganzen durchgedrehten Leuten, die irgendwie in einer fremden Sprache sprechen mittlerweile, das hat schon auch so ein bisschen so Zauberlehrling-Charakter.
Das war mit dir mit dem Internet damals genauso. Da haben wir auch eine Sprache gesprochen, die keiner verstanden hat und er dachte auch, Internet ist böse, böse, böse.
Ja, ging aber nicht so um Geld erst mal, sondern ging ja um Freiheit und Kommunikation und Lernen.
Ist doch viel wichtiger als Geld.
Ja, ist viel wichtiger als Geld, aber die Leute, die mit Geld arbeiten, sehen das natürlich ganz anders.
Das kann schon sein, dass da eine Menge Nachteile kommen, aber ich glaube, meine persönlichen Vorteile sind größer.
Ja, deine. Da hab ich jetzt gar keinen Zweifel dran.
Und von vielen an, also von allen Menschen so. Manche übertreiben es, ein bisschen mag sein, aber es werden sie so oder so tun. Und auch kann man das jetzt gut oder schlecht finden, es wird auf über uns herüber rollen. Du kannst das nicht verhindern, also es kommt, das kann man nicht. Die können das jetzt alles wegverbieten, aber du kriegst das nicht mehr weg.
Ich weiß, darüber rede ich.
Und ich muss mir keine Gedanken machen, wie die das verhindern, wie die großen Firmen, die Dealer oder wer auch immer das Geld dahin und her schiebt. Das ist nicht mein Problem.
Weil?
Weil, warum? Das ist nicht meine Sorge. Das sollen die doch machen. Also, das ist vielleicht nicht toll, aber ich muss zumindest mir nicht überlegen, wie man das verhindert. Das ist nicht mein Job. Das können andere tun.
Na gut, ob ich mal drüber nachdenken kann, kann man ja schon. Man hat ja so einen gewissen moralischen Kompass, den man ja dann schon auch machen will.
Aber das Problem ist doch wie beim Kryptomessenger. Die sagen, die Terroristen können den Kryptomessenger benutzen. Dann sage ich, ja, kann sein. Und vielleicht sollte man gucken, wie man das verhindern kann. Am Ende ist es aber, ich kann den Kryptomessenger ja auch nutzen, dass ich privat mich unterhalten kann, ganz normal, ohne dass da einer mitliest. Und das könnte ich auch sagen.
Kryptomessenger töten keine Menschen, Menschen töten Menschen. Um den tollen NRA-Spruch mal einerseits abzuwandeln, kannst du auch gleich auf Kryptocurrencies münzen.
Ja, Kryptocurrencies kaufen keine Drogen, Menschen kaufen Drogen.
Es kann aber schon sein, dass diese Steuergesetze sich ändern.
Ja, wir reden aber jetzt hier über ein Solidaritätssystem. Und das ist schon noch mal ein bisschen was anderes als einzelne Taten.
Ja, aber ich finde halt, also ich meine, das was Denis sagt, ist ja trotzdem, also da kann man ja schon mal drüber sprechen, weil das finde ich durchaus legitim. Zum Beispiel ein Gehalt, oder was auch immer, das kriegst du ja nicht in Kryptocurrency. Das ist ja schon mal accounted sozusagen. Also es gibt immer einen Bezug, es gibt einen Bezug zur realen Welt sozusagen.
Ja gut, aber in dem Moment, in dem Moment, wenn er jetzt in den nächsten Drogenhütten irgendwie aufmacht, die holen sich dann die ganze Patte irgendwie mit Z-Cash.
Wie bezahlt du denn deine Drogen jetzt noch? Wie bezahlt du denn jetzt deine Drogen?
Mit ehrlicher Arbeit.
Ja, aber du musst ja irgendeine Einheit bezahlen.
Ja, ich ziehe das alles selber groß. Mach ich alles auf fernen Inseln, wo das erlaubt ist.
Du hast natürlich insofern recht. Also ich meine, für den kleinen Geschäft zwischendurch gibt es halt immer noch das Bargeld. Wenn ich also 50 Euro irgendwo in Drogen anlege, dann versandet die Transaktion einfach am Schein. Aber du kannst halt keine 50 Millionen, kannst du halt nicht in Bar bezahlen. Aber du kannst halt 50 Millionen in der Cryptocurrency bezahlen. Und da wird es halt dann schon auch schwierig, kritisch. Die illegalen 50 Millionen. Um legale Transaktionen geht es ja nicht. Also wenn eine Transaktion legal ist und beide Seiten die halt auch legal deklarieren, oder sagen wir mal so, eine der beiden Seiten Angst haben muss, die andere Seite würde es legal deklarieren, dann ist es ja egal, ob die Transaktion jetzt zwischendurch irgendwo durch eine nicht verfolgbare Cryptocurrency gegangen ist. Wenn ich sage, ich habe dem Autohändler jetzt hier 50k fürs Auto gegeben und es bei der Steuer angebe und der Autohändler gibt die 50k nicht bei der Steuer an, dann hat er ein Problem. Zumindest wenn er auf Steuer auf Zack ist, sagen wir mal so. Aber was anderes ist natürlich, wenn jetzt der Diktator von sonst wo mal eben für 50 Millionen halt irgendwie Munition kauft, irgendwie über eine Kryptowährung von irgendeinem scheinheiligen Typen.
Das machen sie doch jetzt mit halt Geldkoffern oder zahlen sie halt in Diamanten oder da haben sie ihre Kuriere, wie auch immer.
Aber es passiert halt nicht, also es passiert in einem kontrollierbaren Rahmen. Du hast halt derzeit Möglichkeiten, diese internationalen Transaktionen zumindest in einem bestimmten Maße, sicherlich noch nicht in einem Maße, wie es für uns wünschenswert erscheinen würde, aber zumindest in einem bestimmten Maße zu überwachen und in einem Rahmen zu halten. Dieser Rahmen lässt sich mit so etwas wie Zcash nicht mehr herstellen. Also er ist einfach komplett weg, ist einfach nicht da. Das einzige, was du vielleicht noch machen kannst, ist, du kannst diesem Geldnetzwerk seine Gesamttemperatur abnehmen. Du siehst zumindest, wie sehr es glüht. Du weißt, wie viel Kohle da hin und her geht und welche Summen da bezahlt werden. Und wenn da wirklich Transaktionen im Milliardenbereich stattfinden, dann weißt du, dass die Kacke am Dampfen ist. Das weißt du wahrscheinlich auch schon ein bisschen vorher. Man weiß zwar nicht, woher die Kacke kommt und wohin sie geht, aber man sieht definitiv, dass sie damit mitmeldet. Man kann sie nicht sehen, aber man riecht sie. Das müssen wir mal im Blick behalten. Man darf nicht alles bejubeln, schon gar nicht, aber auch alles verteufeln. Aber mir fehlt in dieser Szene teilweise so ein bisschen, auch so ein ethisches Gerüst.
Aber trotzdem darf nicht Denis recht, wenn er sagt, das Weggehen wird es so oder so nicht.
Aber die Frage ist, auch so etwas wie Bitcoin ist halt irgendwie getragen von Hackern. Das sind die Leute, die wir da kennengelernt haben, teilweise wirklich coole Leute, die vielleicht auch den einen oder anderen Weltverbesserungsplan im Kopf haben. Aber da gibt es halt auch andere.
Auf jeden Fall. Aber ich finde, das ist schon so wie mit den Krypto-Nachrichten, Krypto-Messengern und so weiter. Da könnte man auch sagen, ja, das wird auch negativ eingesetzt und dann kann man das überhaupt gar nicht mehr verfolgen. Das nimmt dann Ausmaße an, die man nicht mehr kontrollieren kann. Und wir müssen dann etwas einfallen lassen, so oblade backdoor-mäßig oder sonst wie, dass es irgendwie Gesetze gibt, die sagen, du musst hier immer irgendwie noch so ein Master Key haben und so, wie das Clipper-Zeugs von damals, weißt du, so backdoors. Und da haben wir auch gesagt, nee, das wollen wir nicht. Und wenn das Terroristen benutzen, ja, dann die, die, ja, die kann man eh nicht überwachen. Und das ist jetzt mit dem Krypto-Geld eigentlich wieder genau die gleiche Story. Ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen Geld und ein bisschen direkter und betrifft vielleicht mehr Leute, aber eigentlich ist es...
Du hast Bargeldkontrolle an den Grenzen. Du hast schon irgendwie solche Maßnahmen.
Ja, aber da wird auch geschwogelt und gemacht und getan.
Ja, du kannst gewissen Grenzen natürlich schon, aber es gibt halt sowas wie Geldwäsche, was meistens über Bargeld funktioniert, ne? Also, ähm, ja, keine Ahnung. Weiß nicht, ob es Cryptocurrency-Geldwäschereien schon gibt. Ich nehme es mal an, also...
Ja, Mixer, dann klar gibts die. Hat doch heute einer nicht gemacht.
Ja, unter Garantie wird es das geben.
Also nicht, dass es ein Problem ist, irgendwie Geld über die Landesgrenze zu bringen, oder? Ich meine, wenn ich hier eine Million hab, geh ich hier irgendwie hin, kaufe Diamanten, stelle mir die Hosentasche, fahr rüber in die Schweiz, verkaufe dir da wieder und schwupp, pass, ein bisschen Verlust. Aber du hast das ganz easy rübergebracht und das findet irgendwie niemand.
Also was ich mir vorstellen kann, ist, dass die Banken diejenigen ja so ein bisschen das Geschäftsmodell wegbricht, wenn die Kryptocurrencies tatsächlich Mainstream werden.
Das ganze Shit muss ja verwaltet werden, dazu braucht man ja.
Dass die halt auch Lobbyarbeit machen werden. Und mich würde nicht wundern, dass wir in ein paar Jahren schon die ersten Lobbying- und Gesetzentwürfdinge dazu sehen werden, das Zeug ganz zu verbieten. Ob das dann durchkommt oder nicht, das sei mal dahingestellt, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Banken irgendwann kalte Füße kriegen.
Also kommen wir zur positiven Utopie. Es führt zur Abschaffung des Geldes, à la Star Trek sozusagen, wo man das einfach ganz weglässt, das ganze System, weil es dann irgendwann komplett ad absurdum geführt wurde. Oder die negative Utopie.
Das ist auch unrealistisch. Du hast ja nie Leute gesehen, die überhaupt irgendwie was machen. Die leben da auf dem Schiff und kriegen alles for free.
Die haben halt das Energieproblem gelöst. Das ist ja die Grundlage sozusagen des Ganzen. Es gibt dann halt einfach keinen Grund mehr. Und du hast deine Replikatoren und kannst halt alles so regeln. Das war jetzt auch nur sehr far-fetchend, aber das andere negative Beispiel wäre dann, es gibt ja nicht nur den Klimawandel und so weiter, der vielleicht prognostiziert diese Zivilisation und Erde und so weiter in diesem Rahmen enden lässt. Vielleicht schaffen wir das auch einfach selber. Genug Möglichkeiten und Tools haben wir schon dafür in der Hand. Vielleicht sind auch die Kryptocurrencies die Einleitung des Ganzen, die Auflösung der zivilen Ordnung.
Oder die Machine Learnings-Apokalypse. Die AAI. Apokalypse.
Oder einfach alles zusammen. Das endet dann wie in so einer guten Serie. Irgendwie alle Handlungsstränge kommen dann am Ende irgendwie zusammen und macht dann macht es einmal kurz Puff.
Meine Vision der Zukunft ist, dass ich ja dann irgendwann so ein Elektroauto in meiner Garage stehen habe, mit einer 150 Kilowatt Batterie. Und dann, wenn der Strom kommt oder wenn er gebraucht wird, mein Auto von selber per Kryptowährung den Strom aus der Batterie kauft und verkauft. Also einkauft und verkauft. Und die ganze Zeit handelt. Und wenn es gut läuft, macht mein Auto halt Geld. Und wenn es nicht läuft, dann zahle ich halt... Dann muss ich zu dem schlechten Zeitpunkt irgendwie laden.
Und wenn es nicht läuft, sprengst du den Terroristen in die Luft. Mit von deinen Bitcoins erwirtschaftest du den Sprengstoff.
Okay, ich würde sagen, an dieser Stelle...
Bricht der Tim ab. Zu viel Gegenwind.
Nee, ich wollte das einfach nur mathematisiert haben. Das habe ich ja nicht getan.
Nee, ich verstehe das schon.
Ich bin da auch gespalten. Selbstverständlich möchte ich gerne die positiven... Wirklichkeiten nutzen. Das ist halt die klassische CCC-Ambivalenz bei der Betrachtung der Welt. Es gibt halt Chancen und es gibt Risiken. Man muss sich beides anschauen. Und ich bin jetzt einfach weder in so einem reinen Jubellager mit, oh geil, Kryptowährung, alles spitze, noch in so einem, oh Gott, oh Gott, die Welt wird viel zu kompliziert. Das darf man jetzt nicht machen. Klar, wird stattfinden, aber man muss sich halt darüber Gedanken machen, was es für Auswirkungen hat. Und ich finde, jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt gekommen, das zu tun.
Aber die Kryptowährung ist ja auch nur ein Teil des ganzen Hype-Trains, also ein Waggon, es war der größte Waggon, aber die Blockchain-Technologie als solches ist ja durchaus auch ein Stück Technologie, in Anführungsstrichen oder als Konzept, durchaus reizvoll. Und da gibt es ja dann auch noch abseits der Cryptocurrencies vielleicht interessante Ansätze. Ich habe mich ja jetzt auch in letzter Zeit nochmal so dazu belesen, was jetzt eigentlich dieser Blockchain-Hype ist und was die Leute eigentlich alles damit anstellen wollen, diese Smart Contracts und so weiter. Und das meiste, was es dazu aktuell gibt und versucht, auf dem Hype-Train mitzureiten, ist ja einfach Unsinn oder es ist einfach so schuld, dass du wegguckst.
Also doch, ich habe es mir nicht angeguckt, dass man das so einfach nicht so richtig verstanden hat. Also in ganz vielen Fällen hat man den Eindruck, die haben das jetzt mit der Blockchain also auch noch nicht so richtig verstanden. Und benutzen halt dieses Wort oder die Technologie vielleicht an irgendeiner Stelle, aber hauptsächlich, um so mit im Blockchain-Hype mitzureiten.
So eine Art Marketing auch nicht. Wir forschen auch mit der Blockchain, wir sind immer gern dabei, blablabla.
Aber ob man jetzt eine Mitfahrtzentrale mit Blockchain irgendwie betreiben muss, das möchte ich mal stark hinterfragen. Aber zum Beispiel ein Gedanke, den ich letztens so hatte, wo ich noch nicht final fertig bin, aber den ich eigentlich ganz interessant war, dieses Thema elektronische Wahlen. Das ist ja vielleicht schon, also sagen wir mal, jetzt vielleicht nicht für die Hauptwahlen und so weiter, aber für Bürger geben mal so eine Stimme ab und so weiter. Das ist ja vielleicht so eine Blockchain. Was denn?
Du hast schon weit aus dem Fenster gelebt.
Wieso nicht?
Jetzt bin ich mal auf die Argumentation gespannt. Ich mach die dann runter.
Bitte nicht.
Ich glaub, da kommt keine.
Naja, also das will ich jetzt mal hören, was du dir da ausgedacht hast.
Ich hab... Hallo, es bleibt mal auf dem Defi gleich. Tim stellt sich gleich hier schon breitbeinig mit seinem Mac.
Aber doch, vielleicht dann hält er kurz die Luft mal an.
Ich schmeiß gleich mit Schafe.
Ja, wieso denn nicht? Also was spricht denn dagegen?
Na alles.
Nämlich?
Na, dass einfach generell elektronische Wahlen sind. Sofern wir jetzt von Wahlen im Sinne von geheime, gleiche, allgemeine Wahlen reden, ist einfach die Hinzufügung von Computern einfach eine Schnapsidee. Das hatten wir doch nur schon den letzten Jahr.
Ja, gut, da bin ich doch auch...
Da händert eine Blockchain genau gar nichts da dran.
Da bin ich doch, also an diesem prinzipiellen Wahlcomputer, etc. Thema, müssen wir gar nicht drüber streiten. Ist korrekt. Also ganz ausschließend im Thema Staat-Bürger-Interaktion möchte ich das jetzt aber auch nicht.
Aber Stadt-Bürger-Interaktion hat ja nichts mit Wahlen zu tun. Das ist ja keine Interaktion, sondern es ist eine Delegation. Man delegiert Macht.
Wir, also zum Beispiel vielleicht, also im Thema...
Ja, wieso?
Ich hab jetzt noch kein Argument gehört. Also mal kurz zu deinem Blockchain und auf... Das ist ja die andere Blase, ne? Also neben dem reinen Geld gibt es ja die Leute, die der Meinung sind, oh ja, Blockchain ist ja eine ganz tolle Idee. Dann kommen dann so Ideen wie, ja, weil das ja quasi so eine ewige Liste ist, in der alles für immer festgeschrieben ist, mit einer zeitlichen Reihenfolge und Verortung in der Zeit. Abgesichert irgendwie, und du weißt, das hat halt stattgefunden und dieser Eintrag wächst immer weiter. Und dann überlegt man sich halt, was haben wir denn so für verteilte Datenbanken, wo wir derzeit so Zentralisierungsprobleme haben, das könnte man doch mit sowas ablösen. Ist auch ein legitimer Gedanke. Und dann kommt dann sowas wie DNS zum Beispiel. Warum sind denn nicht alle Domain-Names irgendwie in dieser Blockchain abgesichert? Also dann steht da drin, wem gehört denn diese Domain und so weiter und welche Änderungen hat es gegeben?
Gibt's schon.
Ja, ich weiß. Gibt auch noch andere Leute, die sind der Meinung, man müsste jetzt Musikkataloge damit machen und einen möglichen Unfug. Das Problem ist nur wieder, um so eine Blockchain am Leben zu erhalten, brauchst du genug Leute, die daran teilnehmen und ein Interesse daran haben, dass das Ding legitim und erfolgreich fortgeführt wird, weil es für sie eine Ökonomie darstellt, in die es sich lohnt, sie zu investieren. Das ist halt normalerweise nur bei Kryptowährungen so.
Das Konzept Blockchain, dass du hier deine Merkel-Trees und die ewige Liste aufbaust, das kannst du ja auch auf einem Note machen. Viele Konzepte klingen erstmal total schwach, weil du denkst, ihr habt ja überhaupt keine Teilnehmer. Aber dieses Ledger-Prinzip, was ja im Prinzip, wie heißt das in Deutsch, ihr In- und Out-Buch, Log File, das haben ja Banken auch jetzt schon ohne Blockchain. Nur da kannst du als Kunde da nicht reingucken.
Ja, das ist halt zentral und nicht dezentral. Aber dezentral, damit sie dezentral sind, musst du dem vertrauen.
Aber trotz alledem, so wie das Banken bisher implementiert haben, entspricht das nicht an der Blockchain im Sinne von Datenintegrität und ewige Liste. Und es kann keiner dazwischen in den Büchern was rausstreichen.
Es sind solche bekloppte SQL-Datenbanken, die sich nicht loswerden.
Genau, und dieses Datenintegere Log File von Ereignissen, die auch nicht mehr im Nachhinein veränderbar sind, also das Blockchain-Grundprinzip, das funktioniert im Prinzip auch auf einem Note. Da kannst du natürlich hinterfragen, inwieweit das für die einzelnen Use-Cases sinnvoll ist, aber geht.
Die Frage ist, was willst du damit gewinnen? Natürlich ist es sinnvoller, eine reine SQL-Datenbank mit etwas abzulegen, wo die Dinge kryptographisch signiert und mit Timestamps abgelegt sind, damit man diesen Einträgen als solchen mehr Glauben schenken kann, insbesondere wenn irgendjemand von der Seite kommt und da reinhakt und irgendwelche Manipulationen vornimmt. Gar keine Frage. Aber das ist ja nicht das eigentliche Versprechen. Das eigentliche Versprechen der Blockchain ist, dass sie das in verteilter Form tut, ohne eine zentrale Entität, die da drauf sitzt und sagt, das ist jetzt hier irgendwie schon das Paktische.
Aber sagen wir mal so, es bietet die Möglichkeit, das zu tun. Es bietet auch die Möglichkeit im Prinzip, dass das ganze Netzwerk, sofern es dann geöffnet ist, sozusagen bestimmte Vorgänge nachvollziehen kann. Aber du könntest es zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel nochmal Bürgerinteraktion, nur so jetzt ohne Wahlen, ja, aber sag mal, du hast jetzt so einen Private Key mit deinem E-Perso, hast eine anonyme Adresse, die sonst jetzt vielleicht keiner kennt, und du stellst jetzt irgendeinen Antrag und kannst das da in der Blockchain irgendwie so einhämmern und das ist einfach unveränderbar beweisbar. Du hast jetzt diesen Antrag zu diesem Zeitpunkt gestellt und genauso ist das für die Gegenseite quasi, der Antrag blablabla beantwortet, in welcher Detailstufe jetzt auch immer, ob das für Steuererklärung oder sonst was.
Ja, die Blockchain liegt offen rum oder liegt nur beim Start?
Nee, also in dem Moment, wo du da mit interagierst, hast du natürlich auch eine... Also alle Teilnehmer haben dann schon natürlich...
Ja gut, aber diese Infrastruktur kannst du ja jederzeit wegforken, wenn du da irgendwie 51 Prozent der Rechenbauer hast. So, und wenn du halt mein Interesse daran hast, die Infrastruktur des Staates und dessen, was da irgendwie geltende Verträge und Anträge sind, irgendwie zu übernehmen, da könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass die kriminelle Energie größer ist als die Gesamtkompetenz der Bundesrepublik Deutschland um ihre eigene Scheiß-Blockchain irgendwie am laufenden Zeit.
Ja, das ist jetzt... Ich meine, du kannst ja auch die Blockchain auf die eine oder andere Weise implementieren. Das ist ja jetzt kein... So hat das zu sein und...
Ja, aber wenn sie dezentral sein soll, im Sinne von... Man glaubt, man hat das Vertrauen sozusagen... Ich meine, sonst kannst du auch einfach weiter dem Staat vertrauen. Da ändert jetzt irgendwie die Blockchain ja nichts. Also ich finde das alles nicht so richtig überzeugend, um mal ehrlich zu sein.
Ich sage nicht... Ich will dich überhaupt von gar nichts überzeugen. Ich würde es gerne mal besprechen, ob es nicht doch vielleicht irgendwelche Use-Cases in dieser Hinsicht gibt. Aber ihr seid jetzt ja schon total anti und wollt gar nicht drüber nachdenken.
Du bist ja gleich mit elektronischen Waren.
Aber die Blockchain ist ja noch ein bisschen anders. Sie ist ja nicht nur transparent, sondern jeder, der da mitmacht, kann ja auch da ranhängen. Wenn du das bei den Wahlen oder beim Start auch so machst, dann ist ja so, dass jeder in diesem Land dann auch da ranhängen können müsste. Nicht nur, dass jeder reinguckt, sondern jeder kann sich auch verändern. Solange halt die Parameter stimmen. Und ob das alles immer zutrifft, das Problem, das man löst, das sehe ich halt nicht.
Aber der Algorithmus oder wie auch immer da Dinge rangehangen werden können, die sind ja frei definierbar für ein bestimmtes System. Das muss ja jetzt nicht genau so wie bei Litecoin oder bei Bitcoin sein. Also ist es nicht denkbar, dass man quasi ein System baut, was vielleicht auch mal irgendwie den Bürokratieapparat irgendwie...
Ja, aber durch die Speicherung änderst du ja noch nicht den Bürokratieapparat. Also ich meine, du fügst zunächst einmal erst mal nur eine Komplexität hinzu.
Vor allem ist die Blockchain ja, die ist ja durch die Hashes auch relativ sicher, weil du kannst da nicht mehr so einfach Sachen ranhängen. Das heißt, um da was ran zu hängen, musst du ganz schön viel Rechenpower aufbringen, die inzwischen gerade bei Bitcoin halt so scheiße teuer ist und sich nur deswegen lohnt, weil da auch ein Wert generiert wird. Nämlich zurzeit 12,5 Bitcoins, die man alle 10 Minuten generiert, wenn man halt den passenden Hasch findet. Und wenn du aber irgendein Problem lösen willst, wo kein Geld generiert wird oder zumindest dann später irgendwann die Transactiongebühren an denen geht, der den Block gefunden hat, dann geht das nicht. Also niemand wird sich hinsetzen und zu Hause irgendwie den nächsten Hasch suchen für viel Stromkosten, nur um irgendeinen Eintrag in einer Blockchain zu machen, der...
Einen Antrag auf Steuerauskunft.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist jetzt halt die spezifische Implementierung für Bitcoin, die bestimmte Probleme damit löst. Nämlich, dass halt nicht irgendjemand da herkommt, irgendwie einen dicken Computer hinstellt und irgendwie alle Bitcoins in fünf Sekunden meint.
Das ist auch bei deinem Problem auch so. Du willst ja nicht, dass irgendjemand die Blockchain ändert. Und damit das nicht geht... Ja, weil dann brauchst du keine. Wenn man die einfach so... Also auch rückwirkend ändern. Das heißt ja, das mit dem Haschen ist ja so schwer, damit man die Blockchain auch nicht rückwirkend ändern kann. Also du musst dir das so vorstellen. Wenn ich jetzt der Superminer wäre und ich hätte super Mining-Mega-Power, dann kann ich mir den letzten Block von gestern nehmen und hängen da einfach 100 Blöcke ran. Dann ist meine Kette länger als die aktuelle und dann stirbt das, was eigentlich bis eben noch die Blockchain war. Und dann ist sozusagen meine Kette die aktive und ich habe dann 100 andere Blöcke zunichte gemacht. Die sind dann nichts mehr wert, weil meine ist länger. Weil die längste Kette gewinnt in der Blockchain und das darf halt nicht passieren. Und das ist halt über, ja, bei Bitcoin eigentlich über Geld geregelt. Also durch das Mining halt teuer ist und das lohnt sich aber trotzdem, weil dafür ein Wert entsteht. Und wenn das nicht gegeben ist, die längste Kette gewinnt.
Aber auch da würde ich nochmal fragen, ist das jetzt per Definition Blockchain so oder ist das eine Eigenschaft dieser spezifischen Implementierung, die du relativ gut durchdrungen hast?
Das ist Teil einer Blockchain, weil du musst ja irgendwie anhängen und du musst sichergestellt sein, dass wenn zwei gerade, also Blockchain heißt ja, dass du was unterschreibst und an was ranhängst, was es schon gibt, also diese Chain. Wenn das aber gerade, weil diese Welt ist halt groß und da gibt es halt Latenzen, weil das Netzwerk ist ja nicht unendlich schnell, sondern hat halt Latenz. Das heißt auf dieser Welt können zwei Leute gleichzeitig den passenden Block finden, der an den letzten angehangen wird. Beide sind valide. Beide haben irgendwie jetzt auch, also bei Bitcoin jetzt, beide haben diese 1200 Bitcoins erzeugt, aber nur einer von beiden kann überleben. Und wer das ist, entscheidet sich da durch, an welchen von beiden der nächste Block rangehangen wird. Weil das ist das einzige, das entscheidet. Es ist egal, wie viele Transaktionen da drin sind, was da für Gelder fließen, das ist total egal. Wichtig ist, an welchen von beiden Blöcken der nächste drankommt. Und das kann sogar passieren, ist auch schon selten passiert, dass durch irgendwelche Umstände an beide Blöcke wieder zufällig an beidenen Block rangegangen wurde, weil die sich nicht gegenseitig gesehen haben und die wieder genau in der gleichen Sekunde das gefunden haben. Dann sind da schon zwei Blöcke, die so gesplittet sind. Aber irgendwann passiert das nicht mehr. Und dann ist eine länger als die andere. Und in dem Augenblick wird jeder an dem Ding weiter meinen und nicht mehr an dem kürzeren Stück. Weil das Längste gewinnt immer. Und dann sterben diese beiden ab. Und alle Transaktionen, die da drin sind, alles Geld, was da drin geschoben wurde und auch was entstanden ist, ist danach nicht mehr da. Es ist weg. Deswegen soll man ja auch diese Confirmations abwarten. Sechs Stück, weil man nämlich nicht...
Jaja, das ist aber richtig. Aber deine Use-Cases drehen sich trotzdem immer genau um diese Bitcoin-Ökonomie.
Ja, aber man muss ja bedenken, wenn du eine Blockchain machst für bürokratische Vorgänge, dann willst du das ja auch nicht zurücknehmen können. Sonst sind deine Vorgänge im Arsch. Und damit das schwer fällt, muss Mining oder muss halt ein Block anhängen sehr teuer sein. Es darf sich für den Angreifer sozusagen nicht lohnen, das einfach mal zu machen. Und das musst du irgendwie lösen.
Und so eine Blockchain, also mit anderen Worten, eine Blockchain macht eigentlich nur dann Sinn. Wenn du ein System hast, wo einfach die Motivation daran technisch Leistung zuzuführen und Energie und Geld da reinzustecken, dass die Motivation so verbreitet ist bei allen potenziellen Teilnehmern. Weil du ansonsten immer fürchten musst, dass es entweder komplett verreckt, weil einfach keiner mehr rechnet. Okay, das eigentlich nicht, weil du kannst ja quasi dann die, dann geht die Schwierigkeit zurück.
Ja, aber erst nach zwei Wochen. Das könnte lange lange dauern.
Ja, das könnte lange dauern.
Das haben die auch schon alles durchdiskutiert. Kann auch alles demnächst passieren, bei 1. August und so, wenn da so Sachen passieren, dann weiß man nicht.
Also das ist auch noch nicht proven. Und ja, aber vor allem halt in dem Moment, wo du ein Interesse daran hast, diese Datenbestände dort sozusagen eine aktive Geschichtsfälschung vorzunehmen. Und du kannst dich dann gegen diese Rechenpower nicht wehren. Also das ist ja jetzt auch, ich frage mich halt auch, was ist eigentlich so, wenn jetzt mal so eine andere Währung, die mit Bitcoin-Hardware irgendwie bekämpft werden kann, und die irgendwie auf einmal eine Besonderheit hat, und irgendwie die Bitcoin-Jungs, die da gerade irgendwie komplette Wasserwerke in Bitcoin-Münzen umwandeln, wälzen, lassen sich mal kurz dafür einspannen, da mal ein bisschen Energie reinzuschicken. Dann ist das Ding doch auch irgendwie, dringendst du das auch im Kreis.
Jeder, der ein bisschen schlau ist, macht keine Währung, die Doppel-Char-256 benutzt, weil da gibt's halt die Asics schon, dann wären sie ja ganz blöd, die wollen ja pre-mine oder das halt, das ganz normal so natürlich wächst oder auch gar nicht, wie man so sagt. Und dann kannst du natürlich nicht einen Podcast nehmen, der schon da ist.
Okay, dann musst du ja immer wieder was eigenes einfallen lassen, wieder abändern. Ja, trotzdem ist es ja durchaus vorstellbar. Also in dem Moment, wo das irgendwie wertvoll wird, in dem Moment, wo das sozusagen die, eine gezielte Attacke oder eine Übernahme einen irgendwie nennenswerten Geldvorteil haben kann und bei Interaktionen mit dem Staat fällt mir da eine Menge ein. Was weiß ich, was willst du machen? Katasteramt? Naja, dann gehört mir auf einmal die Insel, weil...
Das ist ja so eine Blockchain.
Bin ich einfach mal quer in die Blockchain eingeschrieben, hatte den längsten und dann...
Du, ich sage ja nicht, dass das jetzt genau das Beispiel sein soll.
Ja, aber das bedenken halt viele nicht. Man sagt halt jetzt alle irgendwie ja Blockchain, als ob man so eine Blockchain einfach an die Wand malt und dann gibt es die und erhält sie einfach von selbst. Die erhält sich nicht von selbst.
Das ist klar. Aber die muss nicht unbedingt... Also es gibt einfach andere Wege, als es jetzt bei diesen Kryptocurrencies aktuell gelebt wird. Weil die haben natürlich, wie wir alle wissen, bestimmte Interessen, wie sich die Währung entwickeln soll, wie die verteilt werden soll, wie die sich im Wert steigern soll, wie die gegen Double Spending und alles Mögliche gesichert werden soll. Aber ich finde, man könnte auch mal drüber nachdenken, was man sonst noch so mit anstehen könnte.
Da wird die ganze Zeit, da gibt es ganze Konferenzen, da wurden nur die ganzen Tage Blockchain umdrehen.
Aber auch hier, in dieser Runde.
Ist der Hype-Cycle denn nicht schon wieder durch?
Ja, der neue Hype-Cycle ist Machine Learning und Deep Learning und so.
Ne, aber es geht mit Blockchain auch ordentlich vorwärts. Also guck einfach nach Blockchain-Start-ups. Da gibt es dann diverse Seiten, wo du so Start-ups mit den crudesten und wildesten Ideen findest.
Es gibt auch Start-ups für vegane Hirschfleisch, aber das ist jetzt halt der Hype und der Hype geht auch schnell wieder vorbei.
Ich frage ja nur, weil du ja meintest, hier so mit CCC und einerseits, andererseits beide Seiten betrachten, jetzt in dieser Runde könnte man ja eben mal gucken, was kann man denn mit so einer Blockchain Sinnvolles anstellen, was halt nicht um Cryptocurrencies sich dreht. Das ist ja eigentlich nur mein einziges Anliegen. Ich sage jetzt nicht, wir müssen elektronisch so wählen oder wir müssen dies und das und jenes machen, sondern nur mal, ich kenne mich ja mit Blockchain jetzt auch nicht so sehr aus, wie zum Beispiel der gute Herr Orins da drüben, einfach nur mal ein bisschen die Gedanken kreisen lassen und gucken, was könnte man eigentlich Sinnvolles damit machen, was der Zivilgesellschaft vielleicht irgendwie noch weiterhilft oder auch eben, weiß nicht, also hier so Interaktion mit dem Staat sage ich halt deswegen, weil es einfach scheiße ist, so wie es aktuell ist, mit dem ganzen Papierkram, den man immer noch ausfüllt, mit dem in Berlin sowieso.
Ja, aber Blockchain macht das sicherlich nicht besser. Und vor allen Dingen, Start-ups ist kein Argument. Also Start-ups stehen immer daran.
Ich hab doch Start-ups überhaupt nicht als Argument benutzt.
Doch!
Nee, ich hab nur gesagt, es gibt sie. Aber ich pick sie nicht gut.
Naja, aber Start-ups sind doch nur dazu da, dass du irgendeine bekloppte Idee hypst, dein Geld einsammelst und den Scheiß zum richtigen Zeitpunkt an den dummen verkaufst.
Das ist mir doch alles klar. Ich will überhaupt keine Blockchain-Start-ups, Leute. Ich hab's doch gerade schon gesagt. Darüber nachdenken, was man Sinnvolles damit anstecken kann. Wenn euch nichts dazu einfällt, fine, dann machen wir jetzt das Thema zu. Und dann ist das halt einfach sinnlose Technologie.
Ich bin ja offen für alles. Also kann ja sein, dass einer sich was Schickes einverlassen kann. Kannst ja mal googeln, ob es schon irgendwas gibt, was die Blockchain einsetzt und was nichts mit Währungen zu tun hat.
Wir lassen uns da mal von unseren Hörern belehren.
Ich habe mal gehört, unsere Haare wollen irgendwie so Sachen damit machen, aber ich habe halt noch nichts.
Unsere Hörer, die sitzen jetzt alle schon mit Bauchkrämpfen hier unterm Kopfhörer und denken sich so, aber Jungs, irgendwie das und jenes und so.
Welche Hörer sind noch welche übrig?
Was haben wir denn noch für Themen? Wir können ja mal wieder ein bisschen runterziehen, wie ein normales Bericht.
Ich grätsche mal kurz in den nächsten Halbcycle. Und zwar Machine Learning on a Stick. Da gibt es von Intel jetzt so ein Ding, das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie ein USB-Stick. Den kannst du dir halt in deinen USB-Port stecken und da ist so ein Machine Learning Asic drin. Und dann kannst du an deinem Laptop mal ordentlich Machine Learning machen, ohne dass du irgendwie eine fette Grafikkarte brauchst. Ob das Teil was taugt, kann ich absolut nicht einschätzen.
Ja, das ist auch Marketing, weil Machine Learning ist gerade so shit und deswegen...
Aber zumindest sieht er so aus, als würde er Hitze erzeugen, weil irgendwie der da so Luftdurchlässe hat und so.
Die Frage ist, was macht das Ding? Macht das Ding irgendwie fertig gerechnete Profile, einfach die Erkennung befreien?
Beides, beides. Also du kannst damit lernen und du kannst damit halt dann hinterher mit gelernten Netzen dein Kram machen.
Was ist da drin? Das ist einfach eine Vector-Unit?
Machine Learning.
Ja, das ist einfach ein Vector-Processing, okay. Vector-Prozessoren. Quasi eine Grafikkarte ohne Grafik.
Ja, und der macht dann halt halbe Genauigkeit, weil man das genau braucht bei Machine Learning, kein Double und nichts und dafür ist er dann zugeschnitten oder wie. Und kostet was?
70 Euro, glaube ich.
Uiuiui, das ist schon gar nicht so wenig. Ja, keine Ahnung.
Find ich jetzt für Spezial-Hardware 70 Euro nicht so viel, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, kommt halt drauf an, was das Ding kann, aber wenn einer das wirklich richtig und ernsthaft betreibt, dann steckt da sich doch eh so eine dicke Grafikkarte da rein, oder? Und macht das damit. Oder hier von Nvidia diese Pascal- oder Tesla-Karten, wie heißen die?
Keine Ahnung. Ich wollte es ja nur mal anbringen, dass es jetzt sowas gibt. Ob das was taugt oder nicht, das sei einfach mal dahingestellt. Aber ich fand es ganz spannend, dass irgendwie zumindest so eine Firma wie Intel der Meinung ist, man müsste sowas jetzt auf den Markt werfen.
Nein, nicht nur die Firma wie Intel. Ich meine, Apple wird uns jetzt mit dem nächsten iOS das in Millionenfach um die Ohren schmeißen, weil irgendwie jedes iPhone quasi in so eine Machine Learning-Anwendungsmaschine umgewandelt wird.
Ja, die Frage ist, ob das nächste iPhone, also die nächste Hardware von Apple, nicht dann auch Spezial-Hardware hat dafür.
Das hat schon das iPhone 7.
Spezial-Hardware für Machine Learning.
Ja klar, das ist einfach die Grafikkarte, die da einfach genommen hat.
Ja, aber Grafikkarte und Machine Learning sind an sich schon noch zwei unterschiedliche Sachen.
Aber das ist das, was sie gesagt haben, dass sozusagen in dem iPhone 7 das alles Hardware beschleunigt ist, was sie da mit Machine Learning mäßig machen.
Naja, gut, die Sachen, die man halt beschleunigen kann mit einer Grafikkarte.
Genau, es sind ja im Prinzip alles solche Architekturen.
Na ja, Apple wird das auch hier durchgebenchmarkt und geprofiled haben. Und wenn sie dann irgendwie ein bisschen Energie sparen, indem sie das auf einem Grafikstein machen, dann machen die das natürlich da, ne?
Können wir doch auch mal ein bisschen früher aufhören? Hätte ich gar nichts gegen.
Das hätte der Fess aber noch kurz erzählen. Das ist ja nur so klein. Ich hab ja zu Hause einen Rechner mit zwei Platten, wo so ein ZFS-Mörer draufläuft. Und bei ZFS, wie soll man sagen, da wird alle fünf Sekunden werden die Daten eigentlich weggeschrieben. Außer man macht halt einen Call, der synchron ist, der sozusagen Blocking ist. Dann wird es sofort weggeschrieben, damit der Call halt wieder kommt. Also wenn man hier irgendwelche... Die fünf Sekunden sind tunable, aber die fünf Sekunden ist ja auch nur für das, was gecached wird und was irgendwann dann weggeschrieben wird, wo du das nicht sofort auf die Platte geflushed haben willst. So, aber wenn du oft flushed, also ein Synchronus-Write hast, dann muss er das sofort machen. Und wenn du halt zwei Spinning Rust, also zwei Festplatten hast, und das keine SSD ist, dann dauert das halt eben ein bisschen. Und deswegen gibt es bei ZFS so ein cooles Feature, könnte man sagen, das heißt S-Log oder auch Z-Log, sogenanntes Separate Log oder ZFS Intention Log. Da kannst du deine Festplatten, die langsam sind, kannst du noch so eine Art SSD einbauen oder sogar RAM, der battery-backed ist, das würde auch gehen. Dann werden die Daten erstmal dort gespeichert, dein Call kommt sofort zurück, weil es ist ja gespeichert, und das ZFS kümmert sich dann ein bisschen später darum, das auf die Platte zu schreiben. Das heißt, dein System ist einfach schneller im Sachen wegschreiben und der Task ist schneller fertig damit. Von Intel gibt es so eine Mini-SSDs jetzt, die sehr viele Writes aushalten. Die sind zwar gar nicht so schnell, aber die haben eine total geringe Latenz. Also sie sind, wenn du das schreibst, total schnell fertig damit. Das heißt Optane oder Optanen, wie auch immer. Die gibt es als 16 und 32 GB. Das heißt, als Festplatten willst du die Dinger eh nicht einsetzen. Die sind von Intel auch eigentlich gedacht, um Festplatten so hybridmäßig zu beschleunigen. So ein bisschen wie, wie heißt das von Apple? Fusion Drive? Genau, so ein bisschen Fusion Drive mäßig, aber mehr so unter Windows. Und aber genau diese Karte habe ich mir geholt, hab die in meine Kiste mit dem ZFS-Mirror reingesteckt und hab gesagt, hier ZFS Intention Log, bitte auf dieses Ding. So ein Gigabyte hab ich dafür auch genommen, weil so viel ist das ja eigentlich immer gar nicht. So viel schreibt man ja eh nicht weg. Und die restlichen 15 Gigabyte mach die mal als externen Cache. Das heißt dann bei ZFS im Level-2-Arc oder L2-Arc. Und das hab ich gemacht. Und ich hab leider auch nicht so wirklich Benchmarks gemacht und kann das jetzt eigentlich auch nur so in der Theorie sagen. Aber ich finde, es flutscht jetzt minimal besser und ist einfach schicker und ja. Ja, ich glaube für mein System zu Hause, das ist jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben. Aber sagen wir so, für Leute, die so Datenbanken haben, wo viel auch geschrieben wird, was schnell gehen soll, wo du halt nicht warten willst, bis der Write-Call fertig ist. Besonders wenn es halt auch riesengroße Platten-Systemen gibt, wo du so einen Rate hast mit zehn drehenden Platten, da kannst du dann genau so eine kleine SSD nehmen, um die Write-Last auf die Platte so ein bisschen zu entlasten. Und da hilft das schon. Deswegen, wer sowas baut, ist vielleicht auch eher was für Leute, die halt nicht das privat einsetzen, sondern vielleicht in der Firma, so wie Huckel, der auch schon hier dort so Logging-Server in ZFS-Base. Da wird ja auch die ganze Zeit weggeschrieben. Und wenn das ein bisschen zu viel Write-Lust auf drehenden Platten erzeugt, dann nimmt man hier so eine Karte, sagt hier Z-Log bitte da drauf und schwupp, dann ist das Problem behoben.
Also wir hatten sogar nicht nur, dass wir so ein fettes Storage-Array an drehenden Platten hatten, wir hatten auch die schnellen Intel-SSDs für ZIL und dann nochmal zwei für L2 ARC. Also wir haben so richtig...
Die hattet ihr schon.
Ah nee, der L2 ARC ist ja RAM-genau, aber da hatten wir auch ordentlich.
Nee, L2 ARC ist nicht am ARC, L2 ARC ist dann irgendwo auf dem ARC. Also wir hatten wirklich alle Features on. Das Schöne an dieser ist, die ist relativ klein, weil für dieses...
Was ist das denn L2 ARC bitte?
Level 2 ARC, das ist sozusagen nicht der Cache im RAM, sondern der Cache auf einer richtig schnellen SSD. Da kannst du sozusagen eine 500 GB SSD nehmen und kannst die nochmal als Cache nehmen für deinen Multiterabyte Datenpool. Wenn deine Workload halt größer ist als dein RAM, dann machst du so ein Level 2 ARC irgendwie in dein System. Das ist halt schon für die großen Systeme.
Ja, aber meine Erfahrung ist, dass der gar nicht so viel von dem L2 ARC benutzt.
Das kommt auf deinen Workload. Wenn du so ein Monsterbild, um das jetzt mal einfach zu halten, und dein Bild mit bearbeitendes 50 GB groß ist, dein Rechner hat aber nur 32 GB RAM, dann passt das halt nicht in den Cache. Wenn das immer vom Platte geladen wird, dann nimmst du halt so eine SSD, und du hast Hunderte Bilder davon aus so einem Petabyte Speicher oder so. Und du weißt nicht, mit welchem du gerade so arbeitest, dann nimmst du halt so ein Level 2 ARC und dann lagert er das da aus und dann kommt das immer von da.
Zum Beispiel bei unserem Tracking-Cluster, da Summit hat ja Kafka benutzt, da sind halt irgendwie tausende Tracking-Events halt reingesprudelt, aber die Consumer haben immer nur die letzten, was weiß ich, so und so viele Stunden, 24 Stunden. Manchmal musste mal einer ein paar Tage zurück, aber dafür so vom letzten Tag sozusagen mehrfach, und das war dann halt immer im Level 2 ARC und im ARC und kam dann halt relativ schnell, und wenn dann irgendjemand mal sagt, okay, ich brauche jetzt wirklich mal vor 30 Tagen noch mal den Stream, dann kommt es halt noch mal von der Spinning Disk, dauert halt ein kleines bisschen länger, aber alles, was sozusagen im Tagesgeschäft ging, das war dann immer flutschi flutschi.
Das ist schon eher jetzt so für größere Systeme und so. Also für zu Hause ist das alles ein bisschen oversized, aber dieses 16 Gigabyte Modul, da kostete 50 Euro. Und passt auch mit, es ist so ein M2 Format, dieses schmalen Streifen, und das geht mit so einem Adapter halt auch in so einem PCI-Slot rein, den hatte ich noch rumliegen. Und ja, 50 Euro, dann hab ich das verbaut. Gibt's auch mit 32 und das war's. Und was der schön an dem Ding ist, wie gesagt, die Latenz ist total gering, also noch viel schneller als bei so den normalen SSDs. Und ich glaub, die Ride Cycles, die halt abkann, also du kannst den ewig beschreiben so und der geht einfach nicht kaputt. Also normale SSDs können wohl so 1500 Mal beschrieben werden pro Zelle und die können halt deutlich, deutlich mehr. Also wer da rumspielen will, sollte sich das mal angucken. An Fusion Drive, da werden die wahrscheinlich auch genau richtig für. Ob sich das lohnt und warum man sich nicht gleicht, eine SSD kauft, ist eine andere Frage.
Naja, bei Fusion Drive hast du halt das Versprechen, dass du ein relativ großes Volumen hast, wo halt alles, was du oft benutzt, halt sehr schnell ist und der Rest...
Ja, dann ist das genau das richtige Ding dafür.
Also wenn du, wenn du, weiß ich nicht, eine größere Videosammlung haben willst, aber vom gleichen Volume booten, dann Fusion Drive. Dann Fusion Drive.
Ja, spiel ich vielleicht auch irgendwann nochmal mit rum.
Also, naja, ich hatte in dem einen Raid, da war irgendwie noch quasi ein SATA-Port, hatte ich noch über, dann dachte ich, naja, jetzt kaufst du auch irgendwie so eine ganz kleine SSD, die kleinste, die ich gefunden hatte, hat irgendwie 60 GIG. Nämlich da irgendwie ein Viertel oder so für Zill und den Rest für L2 ARC benutzt. Aber die Daten, die waren immer so, dass es völlig overkill war, weil er nie wirklich viel davon benutzt hat.
Ja, aber das ist zu Hause, ist ja...
Also insofern ist wahrscheinlich auch schon so eine 16-Gig-Karte schon fast übertrieben.
Ja, ich fand's ja gut, dass die so schön klein ist, 50 Euro kann man nicht so viel falsch machen.
So, aber ich bau ab. Am Schluss noch ein...
Ich bau ab, aber vorher...
Ja, da hätt ich dann auch noch einen, bevor ich ganz abbaue. Also ein Abbauer. Aber dann am Schluss noch, immer wenn hier Anna von Freundeskreis spielen hier, so immer wenn es regnet, so als Outro-Song dann.
Regnet ja nicht mehr. Wir haben lang genug gesendet.
Das ist die Dauerregensendung.
Wir haben den Regen weggeflasht.
Wir schalten zu einer kleinen technischen Finesse ins Weltall. Fand ich jetzt mal erwähnenswert. Das ist Yaksa. Das ist eine Organisation, von der nicht jeder weiß, dass es sie gibt. Geschweige denn, was es ist.
Die Japanesen.
Genau, das ist quasi so, was bei uns die ESA und in den USA, die NASA ist. Das ist in Japan Yaksa. Die Japaner sind ja auch ein Teil der ISS. Es gibt ein japanisches Modul. Ein Village, naja, mehr so ein Modul halt. Halb so groß wie das europäische Labor und hängt so ganz am Ende da gegenüber von den Europäern irgendwie rum. Und wie das so ist, müssen ja immer alle irgendwas beitragen. Die Japaner haben jetzt so einen Teil zum Einsatz gebracht, was irgendwie zehn Prozent der Arbeit der Astronauten irgendwie erleichtern soll, weil die Astronauten sind nämlich bemerkenswert viel damit beschäftigt, Fotos zu machen und Dinge zu filmen. Das ist irgendwie etwas, womit die richtig nennenswert viel Zeit verbringen. Ich habe jetzt gerade zehn Prozent gesagt. Die Zahl habe ich jetzt im Ohr, kann ich gerade nicht belegen, aber es war viel. Also viel Zeit ihrer Freien. Was tue ich jetzt in den nächsten Minuten? Und Astronauten haben ja so einen mega detaillierten Plan, was sie so jeden Tag tun sollen. Also der ganze Tag ist von vorne bis hinten auf die Minute genau getimt und wie so Maschinen arbeiten die das ab.
Und was ist es? Ein Astronauten-Selfie-Stick oder was?
Naja, die haben so eine Art Ball, Kameraball gebaut. Also so ein Teil, was einfach in der ISS rumschwebt und filmen und fotografieren kann. Mit einer schnellen Kamera, die wahrscheinlich irgendwie nennenswert hoch auflöst, weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, wie die Specs sind. Und haben das Ganze in so ein Cool-Gehäuse reingetan, wo halt einerseits so ein Gyro drin ist.
Ja, zur Stabilisierung.
Der das Ding sozusagen drehen kann.
Ich glaube, das dreht sich einfach nur, damit das Ding stabilisiert ist, dann eiert es nicht so rum.
Ja, richtig zünden, du hast natürlich recht. Und drehen tut das Ding, indem rundherum in dem Gehäuse an der Außenwand zwölf kleine Mini-Fans dran sind, also Mini-Ventilatoren. Und das Ding kann sich dann quasi frei in der ISS bewegen, weil es schwebt ja einfach erstmal nur rum. Kann aber dann mit den Gebläsen sozusagen ganz feine Stöße abgeben und sich dann eben entsprechend positionieren und stabilisieren.
Darf ich eine Prediction abgeben?
Bitte.
Es wird irgendwann eine neue Version von den Dingen rauskommen und es wird nur noch drei Lüfter haben und nicht zwölf, weil drei reichen eigentlich.
Ich habe so das Gefühl, über sowas werden die nachgedacht haben, aber ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher.
Ja, bei zwölf Lüfter kommt mir echt ein bisschen übertrieben vor.
Aber gut. Ja, die sind halt sehr klein. Wenn du drei große einbaust, dann hast du halt nicht so eine klare Richtungsänderung. Wenn du viele kleine hast, dann kannst du natürlich sehr viel genauer die Richtung bestimmen, mit weniger auch eigenen Vibrationen. Und wenn du da so große Lüfter einbaust, dann haben die natürlich selber auch wieder ein Movement, was sie da mit einbringen. Also die sind ja dann schwerer, haben mehr Masse, bewegen sich, es ist wieder eine Störrotation. Das wird sicherlich auch bei den kleinen eine Rolle spielen, aber so ist nun mal das System jetzt gerade und sie können sich im Prinzip frei in jede Richtung bewegen. Das heißt, während die Astronauten da arbeiten, schwebt dieses Teil einfach so mystisch hinter einem herum und filmt einen dabei. Gibt es ja jetzt im Prinzip auch schon so als Drohne, nur dass die Drohne halt sich die ganze Zeit gegen die Schwerkraft wehren muss.
Und das Ding nicht.
Das schwebt da halt einfach so um und kann sich einfach beliebig im Raum positionieren und kann dann auch ferngesteuert werden. Das heißt, die eigentliche Kamera-Bedienung kann jetzt vom Boden aus gemacht werden. Oder dann, wenn das Ding mit entsprechender AI, wenn du da den Machine Learning Stick da reinsteckst, dann kann das Ding vielleicht...
Cool, irgendwann werden sie so einen Teil auch mal rauslassen.
Ja, da funktioniert es aber nicht, weil die Lüfter nicht drehen. Also, ein bisschen Atmo brauchst du da schon. Es sieht so ein bisschen aus wie der kleine Bruder von Eve aus dem Film Wall-E, finde ich.
Ja, stimmt. Stimmt, so was hat es.
Also, aber du warst ganz niedlich.
Das ist niedlich und vor allem auch so eine geile, einfache Lösung.
Das ist eigentlich eine relativ offensichtliche Idee, dass man das so machen würde.
Ja, man muss halt auch erstmal zusammengekloppt bekommen in so einem kleinen Teil mit allen Anforderungen, die du halt so erfüllen musst. Aber das ist natürlich super, weil davon kannst du natürlich auch beliebig viele zum Einsatz bringen. Also eigentlich könnten die die ganze Zeit irgendwo die Astronauten beobachten, die ganze Zeit irgendwelche 3D-Videos machen. Also das ist jetzt keine 360-Grad-Kamera, das wäre dann wahrscheinlich der nächste Schritt, dass du quasi mehrere Kameras hast, aber die werden sich hier erstmal darauf konzentriert haben, eine zu haben, die richtig korrektes Foto macht.
Ich glaube, der nächste Schritt ist ein ganz anderer. Da machst du vorne einen Arm drauf und dann räumt das Teil von alleine das nächste Versorgungsmodul aus und den Müll wieder zurück ins Versorgungsmodul. Das nicht, weil du musst ja schon ein bisschen auch handwerklich geschickter sein, als jetzt nur so ein Ball mit einem Arm dran. Aber für so simple Sachen, wie gesagt, Versorgungsmodul ausräumen, Müll zurückräumen und so weiter, müsste sich so ein Teil eigentlich ganz gut eignen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so die simplen Jobs sind.
Das Beispiel war jetzt schon relativ komplex. Ich weiß, was du meinst. Du willst halt so für Daily Chores irgendwie... Aber da ist wahrscheinlich das jetzt wirklich der beste Ansatz gewesen, weil das wirklich eine sehr überschaubare Tätigkeit ist. Ja, das bringt uns glaube ich so ein bisschen ans Ende der Sendung. Ach so, wir haben ja dann noch unseren Freund.
Was ist hier damit?
Was?
Das sollten wir vielleicht noch erwähnen. Es gab von Jens, von Jens gab es eine Kiste. Neuzeller Kloster Bier. Was war das? Küritzer Mord und Totschlag. Genau, ein richtiger Mann.
Schwarz Bier, weil wir wahrscheinlich immer hier so viel Mord und Totschlag machen in der Sendung.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, so viel durcheinander geredet oder so.
Wo ist denn unsere Dauerregensendung? Wo ist denn Küritz überhaupt?
Da, wo das Bier herkommt. Es kommt aus Neuzelle.
Neuzelle?
Neuzeller Klosterbreu.
Ach so, ich dachte, das hieß Küritz.
Es gibt nicht nur Zelle, sondern auch Neuzelle.
Also was jetzt? Aber es heißt doch Küritzer.
Das Bier heißt Küritzer Mord und Totschlag, warum auch immer es so heißt. Vielleicht wird da von Jens noch die...
Da war doch noch so ein Brief dabei. Hier, du hast ihn noch.
Nein, das ist der Brief.
Küritz an der Knatter.
Ich lese mal kurz den Zettel vor.
Bitte schön.
Danke für viele Stunden Freak Show an bei themengerechtes Bier zur Unterstützung der kontroversen Diskussionen.
Das sag ich ja, weil unsere Diskussionen immer wie Mord und Totschlag sind.
Mord, Totschlag und Blockchain. Achso, wo wir gerade bei Mord und Totschlag sind, da gibt es ja noch... Das müssen wir auch noch verkünden, oder?
Wer lange wisst, ist ja Flash schon seit Jahren auf dem Pflegebett.
Auf der Intensivstation.
Und die Eltern, also Adobe, haben jetzt beschlossen, dass sie 2020 die Lebenshalt in Maßnahmen einstellen werden.
Lass mich raten, sie verkaufen es dann an Microsoft? What's Flash?
Flash is dead, baby. Flash is dead.
Vielleicht lernt dann auch noch die letzte Webseite, dass das irgendwie eine blöde Idee ist.
Zum Beispiel spiegel.de.
Die ist ja halb hinkriegen, aber halb nicht, was besonders nervig ist.
Also, ja.
Gibt da noch mehr?
Nein, mit einem Mobile-Browser kriegen sie es wunderbar hin. Selbst wenn du auf dem Desktop deinen User-Agent auf iPad ändern, das geht's.
Noch fieser finde ich das ja, da bin ich neulich reingeraten. Du kriegst halt auch so ganz oft im Education-Bereich, so hier irgendwie, Online-Wettbewerb, teste dein Wissen, bla bla bla. Und dann kriegst du da einfach so eine Flashelle vom letzten Jahrhundert irgendwie um die Ohren geschmissen. Das meinen die dann total ernst.
Mhm, das fühlen sich voll vorne.
Mal abgesehen noch von so irgendwelchen Friseuren und so weiter, die irgendwie den Schuss noch nicht gehört haben, aber ja, das muss jetzt bald weg. Ich glaube, es heißt Berliner Kurier oder so, wenn man da irgendwie die Webseite aufruft, kriegt man auch bei jeder Seite erst mal so einen Pop-Up. Du hast kein Flash installiert! Ja, ich weiß!
By design, man, by design.
Gut, schade, dass man dann immer nicht zurückgerufen kann. Ja, ihr habt Flash installiert, macht das mal weg, aber da hört ja mal keiner.
Genau.
Ja, und spielen wir jetzt noch Freundeskreis?
Jetzt spielen wir erstmal unsere Outro-Musik. Wir haben wieder irgendwie über die Bühne gekommen. Leute, jetzt droht der Sommer, ich weiß noch nicht so ganz genau, wann es weitergeht. Wir werden sehen, bis dahin. Bleibt uns gewogen. Bis dann, tschüss.